Hello everybody, Eepidoki is back and Eepier than ever.
Wait, I gotta, sorry, wait, we're missing one thing to sell
this.
Eepidoki is back.
And I'm so Eepi.
Now more Eepier than ever.
New update.
hello i've been all over the place today uh we had to push
back the stream 30 minutes um originally i was like i told
my manager push it back 15 minutes but then i think he
didn't trust me and he was good to not trust me because i
came back around five around like 4 20 uh blaze it i got
home around 4 20 i had to buy uh new suitcase because my old
way guys didn't remember my Old one broke dirt when I came
back from LA.
So, yeah.
So I had to go buy a new suitcase and then I went to get a
hot pot because, well, I put my suitcase and everything back
because I realized, because I wanted to go to a restaurant
that was next to the place where I wanted to go buy the
suitcase.
But I forgot that it closes around that time that they added
this new thing where they're like, oh, the staff has to eat
around this time.
I was like, wow, the staff has to eat.
I had...
God damn, why can't I get some good service here?
What do you mean the staff have?
I have to eat.
I...
God, I know, right?
It's so hard to get some good service around here.
Anyway...
And the staff have right...
What do you mean they have to eat?
How dare they?
They should be making me food.
I'm sorry.
I'm joking, obviously.
I'm not...
It's not that I don't care about workers' rights, guys.
Anyway, so I couldn't go to the restaurant that was next to
the...
So, like, because I had a plan.
I had a plan because I woke up around, like, 2-ish, because
dad's not here.
Didn't know who I am.
Excuse me.
I have dollar sign, dollar sign, dollar sign.
800k subscriber.
Anyway.
So that put a wrench in my plan because like I had a very
tight schedule in terms of getting everything done because
like I woke up pretty late today.
I woke up around too, but I didn't sleep that.
Okay.
I was going to say I didn't sleep that late, but I slept at
five in the morning.
Anyway.
So, but I did like I, it's been like a long time since I've
been.
been able to, these are like one of those rare moments,
because Dad's at the dog's today right now, so like, these
are one of those like really rare moments where I get to
sleep in, and I don't have to wake up to an alarm, and also
I don't have to wake up to a dog, who needs to be fed and
walked.
So it was like, this is my one chance to just sleep as much
as I can without two alarm clocks.
Well, so I just went for it.
I was just like, I woke up around like 11.
I was like too early and I went back to bed.
I was just like, I woke up, I was like, oh, that was nice.
I feel so refreshed.
I checked my phone.
So I was 11 a.m.
And I was like, too early.
And I was like, if I wanted to wake up at 11, my dog would
still be here.
Like, so I just, I was like, I closed my eyes again.
I was just like Why am I waking up 11 If dad's not even here
to be fed So So I went I just went back to sleep So yeah
This is like one of those And I realized Fuck I need to Buy
a suitcase Buy toilet paper too Because I have only one roll
left So I was like Yeah this is For some reason I don't know
if you guys know staples um but for some reason in staples
you can buy a suitcase and toilet paper um it's like
basically i don't know there's like an american version of
this but the staples is like the Canadian like it's like
office depot basically but in cat but Canadian they
basically originally it's like an office supply store but
for some reason they also sell toilet paper and suitcases
And I'm not really looking for anything, oh, it's here too.
I don't know.
I didn't even realize.
I don't know if it's an American company or a Canadian
company.
I just know I told my American friend about Staples, and he
did not know what the fuck that is.
And he's like, oh, it's like, bra, bra, bra.
And I was like, I guess so.
So I just assume Staples is Canadian.
If I tell something about a company that's like a business
in Canada, they don't know what it is.
I just assume it's like the Canadian version of it.
um so anyway uh yeah so it's an office it's an office supply
store that somehow also sells suitcases and toilet paper um
and also where i got the labubu dubai chocolate what is it
called it was a labubu dubai chocolate but it had a specific
name to it i it was a ladudu i don't even remember i because
i was like guys guys look at this labubu the booboo to buy
chocolate i bought but it's the same place where i bought
the little boo boo to buy chocolate um i don't remember the
name uh what uh what it was called when i bought it because
i was like oh my god guys was it the lafu foods oh my god it
was yeah the lafufus um anyway so uh i also got some mini
melts too um because i i don't know it was just i was just
like, you know, I went outside.
You know, you're just like, I'm outside.
I might as well, like, buy whatever the fuck I want.
Like, when will I go outside again?
I say as I'm going to be going on vacation next week.
Like, it's just like, oh, you know, it's just like, well,
I'm outside.
It's time.
It's time to pull out the plastic card.
Yeah, I might as well treat myself.
I got myself some melts too oh i fucking love mini melts but
i don't get a chance to have that because like a lot because
it's like you know it's like this it's like those little
tiny little little circle ice creams um anyway so then
obviously i was like okay i'm gonna get hot pot because it's
like on the way as well so then i was just like i'm like
fuck yeah i might as well get hot pot since it's there i
haven't had hot pot in a long time so it's like those like
miniature hot pot places It's not like I get entire hot pots
of myself.
It's like one of those places where you get like those like
your own little pots and then like a mini pots and stuff.
And you can just like put your, like choose your own
toppings and stuff like that.
So I did that.
And I got Pokemon.
Oh yeah.
And then also I bought Pokemon.
There was a Pokemon card pack.
And at the Staples too.
And I was just like there was only two packs left.
god like by the way i never i don't buy pokemon cards i
don't do pokemon stuff because like um i'm not a huge fan of
the the scalping culture of tcgs now um and also like i'm
just not a fan of like the community behind around
collecting pokemon cards because of how bad it's gotten um
and there's a lot of like people who are just like pose this
is posers or larpers i don't remember there's like a word
for them but like they're not actually like collectors
they're just like pretend like for like cloud and stuff
these days like just for like numbers and viewership so it's
just it's been like you know I'm not like a I'm usually I
don't buy Pokemon cards but um anyway so so the thing is I
saw two packs in the wild you know I saw two packs in the
wild and then I was just like uh I was like I feel like I've
never seen Pokemon card packs in the wild like anymore you
know like I don't know like they like are locked behind a
glass case or like they just don't like they just don't
exist anymore because the scalpers got him you know so so
it's so fucking rare so I was just like oh my god like I
feels like I found like a shiny Pokemon like a wild Pokemon
pack out there like that hasn't like and there's two left
that was at staples and i was just like oh my god like i was
just like i it's like i saw a unicorn for the first time i
was like could it be could my eyes deceive me a wild pokemon
card pack like i thought they were extinct like i thought
they were all locked in captivity how how is this possible
and and yeah so so i was just like gasp so i bought one
because i was just like i don't see them anymore anyway like
oh my god look like it's not a myth these are actually real
anyway biggest mistake of my life i got jack like i like
texted a friend and was like i bought pokemon cards uh also
i watched mating season so please don't judge me and then By
the way, when I was eating hot pot, I was watching mating
seasons.
For those who don't know, mating season is from the creators
of Big Mouth.
And I ran out of shows to watch.
You know, at that point where you ran out of shows to watch,
because I already finished the newest season of Futurama.
And also the newest episodes of Rick and Wernie.
And also, like, the newest seasons of Bob's Burger and
American Dad and everything and The Simpsons.
So I ran out of shows to watch.
So then I was just like, well, there's this show called
Mating.
season from the creators of Big Mouth.
And so I was just like, you know what, let's I'll give it a
chance.
Like,
I'll give it a chance.
I'm gonna go give it a chance.
And so, my host, she's adorby.
I also watched, I, okay, but for those who are newer
dragoons here, finished big mouth like uh wow i told you
guys like i was like i told you guys and i told you guys to
not judge me and so you guys shouldn't be judging me because
you promised me you wouldn't judge me for for watching it uh
it's a really bad show it's like watching a train wreck but
you can't not watch it like you can't turn your eyes away
from it it's like it's like you're on you're doing like meth
and then like you just couldn't stop doing it by the way I
don't do it I don't do any drugs but it I if I did I would
feel I would feel like this is what it's like to do meth I I
think watching a big mouth is what I think is what people
think doing meth is like I don't anyway don't do drugs I
it's really bad it's a it's a very bad show but
It's a very, very, it's a, it's not a great show, but it's
like, when you have nothing to watch, you base, it's like a
show I just pop in, pop on when I'm eating or like, uh,
don't do drugs, kids, you might want, it's almost like
watching Big Mouth.
I think that's a good drug, like anti-drug PSA.
Like, if I've been good anti-drug PSA, you guys, doing drugs
is almost like watching Big Mouth.
anyway so um so i want i checked out mating season i'm on
episode three don't keep watch more than one episode so
anyway i'm on episode three now and it it's basically so if
you guys don't know the premise of big mouth it's basically
about teenage like what it's like to go through puberty and
it teaches you about like puberty and like sexual education
and then mating season is sort of like the equivalent of
that but like what if they're all animals and yeah like and
fun his and fun animal facts too so so that's mating season
it's like puberty for animals but it's not really puberty
it's more so of like mate quote unquote mating season and
what if the fun facts about animals you know so so it's like
furry yeah it's like furry big mouth uh i didn't ask from
this so okay anyway back to the pokemon cards so uh i told i
i was like telling i found pokemon cards and then he was
like don't oh don't open it like uh like do it on And then I
was just like, I opened it.
In the middle, it would be like, I got Pokemon cards.
They're like, I just like, I didn't care.
Like, I'm not a collector or anything.
So I just legitimately, I was just like, I don't know.
I think my eyes was like, I don't even know if it's a good
card pack.
Cause I know some, like the more, um, oh, purists, like the
Pokemon card purists, um, uh, are like, oh, you got to open
it like this.
in front or whatever the fuck or like don't buy these packs
because these are not known to have hits or anything i i
don't care i just saw wild pokemon pack and i was like i've
never seen this before in 20 years and so i was like so uh
so anyway i got nothing no hits whatever i don't know i just
know like if there's if it's good it'll be like super shiny
and everything and i just got like a normal hollow card or
some shit i think that's what's called because i used to get
pokemon shorts so i know all the random ass terms and
everything um so i got like uh just a one a hollow card or
some shit and that was it like that was all i got like i
would know like you would get like full art or something if
it was a really good card pack i think my card pack was for
those who are like pokemon card collectors it was like the
mega dark evolution pack i don't know I think that's what
it's called.
It's like in my jacket.
I legitimately just bought it and just stuffed it in my
jacket.
I did not care about the condition of my cards.
I...
Oh, it was like, was it a pitch black or some shit?
I think that's what it's called.
Pitch black.
Yeah, Mega Evolution pitch black card packs.
Yeah, I think that's what it's called or some shit.
So, those were the uh scalpers are cringing right now is
that are those i don't even know they're good packs or not i
just don't uh for those scalpers out there check the staples
out check out staples there's one more wild pack there's a
wild pack card that's still out there i don't know if it's a
good set or not i don't know i just i just fucking bought it
and ripped it like that's your essay thank you for the super
chat they can think You know a lot of us just watch YouTube
videos instead of that.
It was super chat.
Thank you.
I heard in Japan They started doing like a little quiz for
scalpers because scalping is so bad right now like
everywhere in the world So if you want to buy Pokemon cards
in Japan, they'd be like If you are a Pokemon fan, what is
your favorite Pokemon?
Like what they'll give you like a little Pokemon quiz or
something like what are the types of?
type the the yeah they'll actually quiz the scalpers to see
if they're actually um if they actually uh know what pokemon
is like yeah name every pokemon if you're a pokemon fan and
yeah they're doing face id too because of how bad scalping
is now and um um and also uh there's like some stories in
the states from what i've heard they start ripping like they
start cutting the packs and like ripping Just so like
scalpers can resell them because it lowers the resale value
if the packs are damaged.
So some stores started like cutting the packs and like
removing tags on it and stuff just so they can lower the
sale value for scalpers.
And then I know like I've also heard that not only like...
Because it's like, I don't know, so weird.
It's so weird because it's like not just Pokemon, but also
like the...
TCG scene right now is like so bad for scalpers and
collectors and like just larpers and so like people were
just getting into it for the money um because it like hit
like the Disney TCG I don't know you guys know but I love
okay I remember when the Disney TCG first came out and then
I don't remember I told you guys this story before but like
it was around this time with like me and Sachi were And like
we we bought like the Disney it was a long time ago But it
was like we bought like Disney the Disney TCG pack because
it just came out And I thought it was so cute like Lorcana.
Yeah, and at that time It was not that popular when it came
out But like we were like I think we were at a board games
cafe It was so long.
We were at a board game cafe and they had like And they had
like a Lurkana decks that we could play with and everything.
So at that time, like they weren't that pop.
I don't think they were like a popular collecting thing.
They were like people actually played it.
And they like not recently came up, but it was around that
time when it sort of just came out.
And I was I really liked the art.
So we were just looking at the artwork of the cards.
We were looking at the artworks of the cards because like,
you know, we're both we both like she still draws.
I used to draw.
So I was like, oh, these are so, the artworks are so pretty
and everything.
So we're just browsing through it.
I remember I bought a pack because I was, I really, really
liked the card artwork and everything.
And, and at that time I knew that like, Lurkana was like not
that popular, even though like it just came out because the
TCG scene in general is like, wasn't like everyone was just
focusing on Pokemon at that time for TCG.
So like all the scalpers and everything was just on, was
just on, like on Pokemon.
But now, oh my gosh, I know like I still have those cards
too, like somewhere.
I think it's like on my countertop because I had, I know it
must be like really damaged right now the pack.
Even if I had rare cards in there, like I did not care about
the condition of those cards.
And like even if I even had rare cards, I don't even know.
just stuffed it in my bag and just been like like jingling
around in my bag like great like i won't be surprised if the
edges are creased up or damaged or some shit uh and they
were like one in the first like the the the early sets too
so anyway um um anyway so i i found out recently that there
was They've released some like exclusive sets or some shit
at Disney stores where you can only get at Disney stores.
And then they had like there were like scalpers like
lighting up for like lighting up for like hours to to like
buy the to like buy those cards and everything like the fact
that like TCG scalping has gotten to a point where like it's
just infiltrating like different TCGs now.
Like, even, like, the Larkana sets, too.
I was so surprised, because I saw it, like, on Twitter.
They were talking about how, like, people were really mad.
Like, the fans in the community of Larkana was really mad
about, like, the exclusive card sales at the Disney stores
because, like, the scalpers got a hold of them.
And, like, some of the, like, actual players, like, actual,
like, people who are, who like the game or were in the
community couldn't even get the cards anymore the scalpers
were all lining up for hours and hours for it and um and so
and then it also infiltrated like the pal you guys see the
pow world cards i didn't realize i remember i saw like pow
world was advertising their own tcg set at adamant expo i
didn't realize how like apparently just released or some
shit and the pow world cards just came out and like there's
some cards already going for like 2,000 plus dollars on eBay
like getting scouts right now and it yeah yeah like I was
just like what like yeah so some cards are going for like um
2,000 plus dollars like individual cards of the power world
TCG and I was just like oh my god it's like every TCG is now
infiltrated um i even remember like the um like some like uh
the gamer subs cards too the v cards are also being sold for
a lot on ebay and everything and it's like it's just like i
don't know it's so weird it's i feel like because it's like
i don't know it's just so weird to find like these like
cardboard cards going for thousands of dollars yeah um yeah
um I just I didn't realize like how bad because like you
would think I thought it only I thought it would only um
infiltrated uh like I thought it was only it was like a
confined space like you know confined within Pokemon cards
but now it's spread to like now it's spread towards like
every TCG possible like because I guess they're like well if
Pokemon can do it so can I you know and then uh the what was
it riffbound i heard like riffbound is really bad right now
too because that's like the the riot the because even riot
was like everyone's doing tcg i'm gonna do it too and they
throw their hat in the ring it's like it's my turn we have a
hundred plus champions that's enough for for poke that's
enough for league of legend cards i'm gonna go in too
So even, yeah, get in the trend before, yeah, you gotta get
in on it too.
Because it's like, it's like, because gotcha is so, I don't
know, gotcha is a disease now.
Like physical gotcha, gotcha pond in terms of like, like
everyone's doing blind boxes.
Everyone's doing like, like some sort of gotcha-esque thing.
And like, we all just want the hit, you know?
Like, at one point, I wanted to do like a little gotcha
thing.
too for merch because i thought it was a really fun cute
idea but then now like slowly i feel like people's
perception of blind boxes and like gotcha pawn and stuff
like that is like slowly shifting i feel like because like
obviously yeah it's like everything is gambling down
so it's like uh it's like everything is it's all gambling
now like all like randomized like everything is like
everybody's doing blind boxes everybody's doing tcg um
everybody's doing like like gotcha pond and everything yeah
usually it's like rare but now i feel like everywhere i look
it's gotcha um it's a gambling world we let it ride every
day every hour every second
um uh so i i just thought it was so i thought it was like
really interesting because like like the fact that like you
know even league threw their hat in the ring as well there's
like the my even my like i mean my little pony tcg has been
around for a while and it blew up in china um to the point
where like that's why my little pony is so fucking popular
again like they had like a second life um uh research
insurgents because of how big um chinese my little pony tcg
is um like um and to point where like they exported it out
back to uh back to n a and now like now there's like the
chinese tcg like the my little pony tcg as well um anyway
enough about that today we're gonna be
like everyone's like I don't I it's very smart of me um it's
very smart of me to do two Rogue lights in a row uh I I
don't know I was just like I don't know I went from ball and
gun gamer to rogue like streamer but jokes on you I've
always been a rogue like streamer I feel like other than
shooter games like Road lights are my like are my my second
favorite genre I just I don't know There's just like it's
just it's I guess it's the gacha inside the gambling
addiction inside me Where I just I just love seeing the
numbers go up Um, so it's a roguelike game where from what
I've heard people were saying that it's really fun And it's
uh, it's another roguelike and I hope I do not get uh, I
hope I don't get stuck in another circle of hell today Uh, I
don't know if it's gonna be like yesterday Where we're gonna
have to take myself out uh where i have to be stuck in the
prison of my own making
so basically um it's a game where uh from what i've heard
people were saying it's really fun um and uh it was
basically like it it's like one of those games where you ask
the question how many dudes does it take to take on a
gorilla you know um And, and so, so you just start throwing
dudes in it.
You start throwing dudes at the gorilla until you beat the
gorilla.
I assume that's what it is.
And I know that there was a demo about that during, like,
what's it called Steam Fest, where they promote, like, indie
games.
And apparently these were one of those games that did really
well during Steam Fest.
So, and I saw one of my friends playing it, too.
So I decided, you know, I'm going to check it out.
It's a roguelite.
Like I said, I love roguelite.
So, it doesn't hurt to try out.
another roguelike, even though it's like back-to-back
roguelikes.
Anyway, how many dudes can you take, guys?
Jagata, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I was actually going to comment how your schedule was having
a conversation to it itself by playing how many dudes and
nothing to declare.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
In a fight, of course, guys.
In a fight, right?
In a fight.
I'm talking about in a fight, right?
Guys, that's your answers, right?
Please ask the gorilla.
Rice, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, Miss Bird.
I'm here to pay my royalties and beg you to not release an
outfit so close to Akai next year.
Please, thank you for the Akasupa.
Rice, thank you, thank you.
You know what?
Because you asked so nicely.
I'm going to make sure I release the outfit during off guy.
Or a day before off guy.
Thank you, Miyaka-supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, there you are.
Evil.
All right, so how many dudes?
Again?
All right, that's my dude.
He's a regular dude.
All right.
Oh, he's gonna fight 10 toddlers.
So how how guys can you take on 10 babies?
You literally already did that level.
You know what?
Guys, you want to see me do it again?
All right.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Feed up the kids.
That's right.
Show us welcome them into the new world.
Nice.
I can take on so many.
$20.
All right.
Let's claim it.
Oh, I got $100.
Bro, if I get $100 just to beat up babies, hooking it.
When can I do it again?
All right.
Oh my God.
That's a lot of reading.
It's not off.
Oh, a dokey outfit.
Rubio, Papa, Smurf.
Thank you for the super chat.
It's like, it's like the baby fight club.
I told you guys, right?
There was a daycare center that opened a baby fight club
and...
like a jerk yeah so there was a i'll tell the story again
but what um there was a daycare center got caught for
operating an illegal baby fight club with like people's
babies um all right hits direct damage injects toxins into a
target reducing jacquard i think it's super chat thank you
thank you by five percent i cast or wizard dudes like wizard
dude cats a fireball every three seconds that are dealing.
Okay, poison is always good.
I'm going to go with poison.
More like Justin Watson.
Thank you.
Thank you, Super Chat.
All right.
Get in here.
We want to fight seven little ducks or three rats and ten
babies.
You know what?
I'm going to fight ten babies.
The rats are a bonus.
Yo!
That's right.
Oh, shit.
Oh, wait.
That's bad.
Oh, it's okay.
My assassins got it.
He's got this.
My regular guy's out, but it's okay.
I got my $152.
Oh my god, trashed some more dudes.
Join right in!
See guys, they heard about the baby fight club.
The rats bit the rats bit the regular dudes' ankles a bit
too much.
Oh my god.
Also, SoundGuy, I don't know.
Oh, I found Universal Healthcare.
That's real?
Oh, dudes gain 10% attack by her.
When a dude takes damage that drops his, he gains cleave for
three seconds.
Oh, they're all good.
Rage bait.
Now, I know this is a...
Yeah, now this is a fantasy game.
Universal healthcare.
This can't be in the US.
Please, don't you let the Inflitos experience this.
up the screams of the babies it's not loud enough that's
what we were missing guys the screams of the dying children
i'm up it's the true rage fake give them what they cannot
have you know what we'll catch your rest of the even super
chat thank you thank you don't keep peep the regular dude
chat thinking thank you all right either i don't know i feel
like i'd a rage bait or um motivational i feel like
motivation all attack oh oh hey maybe i should have given
him universal health care uh hey you okay there buddy you
know you feeling better all right but but what about health
yeah you you okay there Let's, there's my sound settings.
All right.
Let me know.
Sound guy, here are the settings.
Let me know if any of these look okay.
Insurance.
We lost it.
All right, let's see the kill feed.
I feel like I might need it.
Toddlers.
Did you, would you like, would you, yes.
I ain't no pussy.
Let me see.
The kids get me.
beat up um all right bring the music down all right really
what no universal health care have a motivational poster of
a cat sing hang in there hang in there guys hang in there
all right i think we're gonna go with two goose and three
little ducks all right my little assassins guy got this yeah
beat them up beat those ducks up uh give me that hunt all
right let's see we got ghost dudes ranger dudes and warlock
dude
all right ghost dudes they when he deals direct damage he
has 30 chance to equalize the hp between the most injured
roster dude and the healthiest roster dude he then heals
them both for it oh wait ghost dude can heal okay let's see
magic arrow when he deals direct down he has 25 percent to
fire the warlock dude has made a path from an evil being
showing his incoming damage his direct damage has 20 i feel
like i should do this one just because he has a chance to
like yeah over a slide up for more duck kicking crunchy yeah
i'm gonna grab the ghost dudes in get in here ghost dudes
you okay there buddy hey hey there does this help you feel
better damn you're kicked up bro bro who's your bro where'd
you get those gains bro Bro, no homo, but, like, damn, bro.
Those are some fucking games you got there, bro.
Bro, what's your routine?
It's okay.
He'll look at the motivational report and he'll feel better.
All right, let's fight the 40 kids.
All right, I think I could.
take 40 children.
Oh my, look at that!
Ghost dude is doing, oh my god, nobody can die.
That's right.
Feed up those whoa!
Don't worry, they didn't explode from a combustion, guys.
Oh, wait, we should get more ghosts.
Wait, actually, I feel like the I don't know.
Do we get another ghost dude so we can, like, live forever?
I feel like, yeah, I'm gonna get more ghost dudes.
Ooh!
Alright.
Dude juice Oh, Dude Juice.
Let's get some Revives Unconscious Dudes If used in the
ranch Revives 10 dudes If used during battle We're used
Okay, we'll grab that That one's for free How much do I
have?
I have $600 What's rotten flesh?
All dudes gain Titan attack speed And 30% run speed When a
dude gets knocked out His cell He doesn't get summoned As a
skeleton And continues fighting For the rest of the Heals
Half of your dudes Dude Juice Damn Wonder what that dude
juice Is made of Dude
um who is the dude's juice guys look it's look it's it's
watercolor it's clear it's it's pure concentrated dude it's
yeah it's made out of dude juice all right do we get the
forbidden stake i don't know if this is if this is like i'm
gonna buy it for now i don't know if i mean Let's see.
I don't want to use it now because, like, it's just one guy.
So, he'll just, he can just rest a little bit longer.
Let's get, let's play two goats and six ducks.
Nothing just like some do-juice to get me out of the
morning.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Well, you know, the super chat.
I passed out 20 times, but here is your do-juice.
Well, thank you.
It's all right.
Go fight the goat!
Oh, yeah, no.
Yeah, there, nobody's.
gonna be dying on my watch.
Yeah!
Kick that girl!
Alright.
We'll grab another assassin, dude.
Only because, like, oh, hey, he's back, see?
He just needed a rest.
Alright, 64 toddlers!
Let's go!
Oh my god, yeah, they're all five.
They're all so healthy.
Alright, sound guys.
Is that better?
The dude's back.
The original dude!
He just needed to rest up, bro.
He didn't need no dude juice.
When a Viking dude deals direct damage to an enemy, he has
5% chance to go berserk, running, gaining 15% attack speed.
When he...
Alright, zombie dudes.
When...
We can have Holland?
When he receives healing.
He has 50% chance to taunt for 3 seconds.
I feel like zombie dude.
Just to like...
like uh he's always going to be getting healing you know the
franken dude has high natural natural
regeneration every second he donates 10 of his current
health oh i'm gonna grab yeah franklin franken i don't know
i we need another tank um but i feel like zombie is gonna go
so hard only because we have two ghosts to be healing yeah
i'm gonna do zombie All right, three goats and 13 size duck
size horses.
I think we can take on those horses.
How many dudes can you take on?
How many dudes, guys?
You're good.
Thank you, listen.
Rich, I think you're thank you.
Here you have, who you have, Doki?
25 more dudes called Bob.
How many dudes?
Oh my god, regular dude got fucked up.
It's all right.
It's all right, regular dude.
You've only lasted You've only lasted two fights But that's
okay regular Dude That's okay You were not meant for
greatness Just a regular guy It's okay bro You're just a
regular guy Dude it's just a normal Okay we're gonna fight
some babies I don't know we can Take on a 28 duck-sized
horses.
Alright.
Let's claim reward.
We want more ghosts or more assassins?
I feel like...
I'll do another ghost.
Okay, frog battle.
At the start of the battle, and every 5 seconds, the
assassin dude throws a toxic bottle of frogs that plague
toxins.
When dude gets knocked out, he has a 15% chance to survive.
Now it's fine.
We only put resources on regular dude.
Ha ha ha ha.
Two juice.
All right.
We're going to grab the toxins.
Two Canadian goose geese or four ghosts.
Canadian geese are scary.
I remember a news story.
I don't know which city it is in Canada, but there was like
a place that was patrolled by Canadian geese and no one
could like go there because if you like infiltrate the
Canadian geese's territory, they would drive you out.
Like they're actually like Canada's demons.
They would, like, chase you away because they're like, my,
this is my turf.
It doesn't matter how big you are.
They're actually fucking scary.
All right.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
Our zombie dudes are going at it.
I would.
Yeah, you don't want to piss off a Canadian geese.
All right.
Trooper dudes.
Oh, my God.
Orbit.
Wait, wait.
We have to.
get trooper dudes when battle starts and every time he calls
down orble strike and or middle strike we gotta get the
orble strike he taunts four enemies um bro this guy he looks
like what's that game called yeah he looks like a hell diver
dude yeah but don't keep for democracy they are geese are
like wasp of a pot yeah uh okay grab that regular dude
wandered into another regular dude a free dude so he heard
about all the dudes though bro he was like bro is this a
fucking fraternity bro where do i pledge for super earth
let's see all dudes gain two percent attack power during
battle per conscious dude on your team up to maximum i mean
one of my dudes is gonna always give you a conscious uh when
dude get knocked out he create burst when he lands dealing
damage equal to meals half your we'll get bean burrito I was
delivering one day and again a Canadian geese were hissing
and biting any car that drove near them I think they popped
someone's tire and Gordon thank you in the super chat thank
you thank you oh we had the ram this regular bro was like
bro is this a ram ram 30 side you know what I'm gonna take
those I think I could I think we could take 37 duck side
horses.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I know.
This is nothing.
Alright.
We'll grab another.
I think we have enough healers now.
You know what?
28 Mallard Ducks.
Get in there!
Oh my god, we have both our regular dudes, too.
They're back.
Alright.
Let's grab.
We'll live forever, technically.
All dudes gain 5% chance crit.
The zombie dude gains 20%.
All dudes gain 15% toughness.
The bonus decay is...
Okay, I'll grab this one.
And I found some...
Dude, sweet dude.
Alright, I feel like the duck-sized horses don't really do
much for us.
Yeah, we have infinite healing, so we're fine.
I can just focus on DPS.
Um...
We'll grab another zombie.
Oh my god, bro, another dude?
Bro, welcome to the dude ranch.
If you are...
If you got lost and you're looking for Ram Ranch, that's the
ranch next door.
But we're the dude ranch.
Not associated with them or anything.
We're not affiliated with Ram Ranch, guys.
We're the dude ranch.
We just happen to be neighbors.
So if you are looking for that other ranch, it is next door.
Dude, sweet, dude.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, shit, another dude.
Bro, so many dudes.
Dean's 20 When a zombie dude takes He has to explode Oh no
Don't explode I need you Uh Their HP He heals half Your
pride knows Our most injured Any overhealing is Bro Let's
grab The dude decks Oh I have to Cause your dude Attune it
For the next three Second or equal Let's see Uh Wait I want
this max hp how much damage wait i i want to take this dude
oh i got all of them i don't dude it's not a choice i get
both oh my god that's i i've never had that feeling before
where i get to have both not a choice dude Dude Oh my dude
Alright give me that dude Alright let's get another orbital
Strike Call us down meteor pumpkin Latte bro that's pussy
shit Bro
That's for the Gordon Think of the super chat Thank you
Thank you Thank you.
Ram, Ranch, Karaoke, Wendoki.
Let's see.
Assassin Dude gains 38 when an enemy receives it.
Habits, Takazat, get, and reapply.
I feel like we should grab that.
Uh...
We're good.
Yeah, you want basic this bitch's ranch.
That's also the ranch next...
The other side next door.
Alright, my dudes are doing okay.
Okay.
All right.
Give me that shit.
Let's grab.
Let's get more orbital strikes.
Dude, nice.
All right, three crabs and five ravens.
I don't even know.
Look at their stats, dude.
I...
Oh, I can reroll shots.
Nice.
Get out of here.
That's right.
All right, let's grab.
Let's grab.
Let's grab another ghost.
That's right.
Now we'll never die.
Ah, right, bro, let's go.
Fucking, holy shit, let's fucking go.
Look at that.
My HP is so healthy.
Your dudes are so good, dude.
I know, right, dude?
Bro, I know.
Alright.
Cionic dudes.
He taunts five enemies when battle starts.
When deflects or take deflect damage, he has a 5% chance to
taunt two nearby enemies.
Every three seconds, the samurai dude.
Attaches to the enemy the lowest HP his direct damage has
50% chance to create a fluke ball that heals for 100% of his
attack he attaches it to a roster due in danger and at first
dude can have up to I feel like we should get samurai dudes
we need more DPS I'm gonna get a samurai dude dude nice all
right 79 ducks that that's right oh my god look
joki dude let's go all right let's grab more samurai oh okay
tattered shoes all dudes gain 5% run speed for each zombie
dude that's in fact when a salmon die reaches he gains
temporary help when dude taunts when dude taunts he damages
the enemy for 50% of his enemy power oh shit i feel like the
parrot right i'm gonna get the parrot just because he has uh
we have dudes that taunt we have three zombies that taunt we
get run speed or i mean run speed will apply to every buddy.
Doesn't the zombie time?
I'll grab the shoe.
And alright, 78 rats.
Yeah, my zombies.
I guess like the run speed applies to everybody though.
Yeah.
He's a dude.
She's a dude.
Raw dudes.
Dude's there are universal.
Alright, spray and pray.
A trooper dude's got a 10% chance to use when he let.
Oh my god, we gotta grab that.
The zombie dude gains 15%.
When any zombie dude, there's a 5% chance that all Insular
Revives.
Four-second cooldown.
Do I have enough money?
Let's grab that.
Bucket, dude.
One horse-sized duck.
All dudes have... Okay, they're... Oh, we're at the boss
fight now.
Oh.
All right.
Sydney, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, that's a big-ass duck, bro.
Oh, my God.
Regular dude is down.
Took the duck-sized...
Oh, the horse-sized duck is going nuclear!
Oh, but the ghost is doing its best to heal them all!
The ghost is, like, not on my watch!
Beat the duck up!
We're having goose tonight!
Oh, shit, nice.
Not even that hard.
Wait, can I add...
I could add more ghosts.
For two seconds.
When dude get knocked out, he has 50% chance to revive.
All dudes gain during battle.
And any dude lands a critical hit.
He gains temporary.
I feel like I'm going to...
Do we get smelling salts or purple heart?
We'll get purple.
I feel like maybe purple heart.
Only because like...
What's it called?
When you're pretending to be a soldier.
Oh, do I have crit stats?
I don't even know.
Do I have crit stat?
I don't remember.
Soul and Valor.
Purple Heart just for the Soul and Valor on my dudes.
Is my crit low?
Oh, grab that then.
I didn't realize my crit is low.
You found a trinket stash.
No, we'll...
Yeah, okay.
The weir gains 10% block chance.
When he blocks, he gains 10%.
He deals attack damage.
He has chance to equal the target's missing to strike again.
When the wielder heals any target, he has chance to equal.
to his crit chance to also heal the most
I feel like inhaler right which one's better chat dude dude
which one would be better for my dudes that oh okay oh
that's where I look at it do we give them a shiv inhaler or
a pet rock I feel like inhaler would go crazy on the ghost
dude that's a Thank you for me, dude.
Do we give our dudes a shiver or inhaler?
I don't think we need a pet rock, guys.
Dude, you don't need a pet rock, bro.
You're never lonely when you're at the dude ranch.
A 5% chance.
Inhaler?
That means a lot, bro.
Yeah, dude, we have each other, dude.
Inhaler on ghost?
You can always count on your bro, dude.
Or the show.
Your hair.
I see more inhaler.
All right, I'll grab the inhaler and I'll give it to the
ghost, dude.
all right now where are we dude we're at the field
bro bro ain't we no no no dude left behind dude no dude left
behind that's funny that's pretty good we look out for our
dudes I gotcha, dude.
Dude, words getting out around that your dudes are pretty
tough.
So I got a bonus fight opportunity for you.
You got pony up the entry for you to fight, but you win.
You can pick after the match your dudes would get restored
back to your current state.
Even if you lose, pretty good deal if you don't think about
it too hard.
You know what, dude?
I bet my dudes can take it.
You're gonna fight it, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, in a fight.
My dudes can take it.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, that's right.
My dudes can...
Oh, my God.
My dudes cannot take it.
What?
Oh, shit.
My dudes cannot take it.
I need...
Guys, I feel so sad right now.
Those snakes got assed up.
Guys, guys, don't work.
Guys, guys.
I feel so shitty right now.
It's time to beat up some more kids.
That would make me feel better.
No, you can just keep sending dudes.
Only one thing can make me feel better about myself killing
kids.
End game.
One leopard?
Okay.
Wild senses.
I think we can take on this leopard.
There's no way.
Oh my god.
Feed him up.
Feed up the leopard.
Who cares if they're an endangered species, dude?
All right, let's get another.
We'll grab another trooper, dude.
And clip that.
Clip that.
It's alright.
It's okay.
Our regular dudes are back up.
We'll take out 130.
be duck-sized horses too we got the orbital strike we need
another orbital strike all right we'll grab another samurai
i feel like we just need more dps not plush we'll grab that
and then okay we are not getting the explosive inners uh
they signed up for it dude they they they've signed the
contract they know what they're getting into dude I think we
need more heals bro I'm not wasting my money on heals dude
we'll get up soon you get healed by the ghost the ghost will
touch you dude but no homo no homo of course it's just like
it's like a bro touch you get healed when that dude touches
you all right we'll get we couldn't get more healers we'll
grab another healer just in case.
Uh, dude, you've got some nice relics there.
I know where to find more, but it's dangerous to venture out
to Dudaverse.
Unprotected.
Let me borrow some relics for 11 rounds and repay you for
bringing them back with a bonus relic.
How about it?
You can par with those relics for a little while, can't you?
Eh?
When the ghost dude casts phase ship, he gains temporary
health at both.
Uh, but when Samurai dude lands a direct hit, what was this?
Uh, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
Okay, we'll get it back before then.
I'll do this one.
23 dog size rats.
That's fine.
A rat's still a rat.
No matter the size.
Like, what the fuck is it gonna do?
Oh, wait, no.
I played Dark Souls.
I've seen what giant rats have done.
Yeah, it's a healing touch, dude.
Just like kissing your homies.
good exactly exactly dude we're four goats oh my god the
orbo strike actually is so good
all right last goat all right we'll grab we want another
orbo strike or more heals chat what would be better i don't
know anymore
what what would be better guys
heels more heels dude all right more heels dude all right 79
geese look at these dudes go oh my god bro he even walked
out of the circle the goose was like i the goose was like
please i get oh hey bro another random dude wandered into
the dude ranch five regular dudes available crop of regular
dudes just hanging around being all weak and dumb.
You want it?
I'll train them up.
The dude whisperer alright!
Oh my god, dude, am I gonna...
Bro, we're gonna get some... We're gonna kill them!
What can we do to the dude, Reg?
Bro, what if we killed them and turned them into a zombie?
Bro, they're charging us for our dude to get bit by a
zombie?
No homo.
dude he's whispering what is he whispering dude it's just an
upgrade dude you're gonna live forever
she's gonna give me five five rounds with it what you're
gonna do with my dudes i said no home though take up these
openings in my dude academy on on the dude We're just
homosexual.
Alright, guys.
Do we kill them?
Give them democracy or turn them into a weave?
What?
Guys, there's just bros being bros, dude.
It's just bros being bros.
Don't send me to the dude farm, Toki.
Don't send me to the dude whisper.
Alright.
What do you guys?
Do we turn them into a weave, kill them, or give them
democracy.
Zombies probably help you the most.
We're gonna kill our dudes.
Do they want to study the sword, dude?
True.
I see it more.
It's between zombies and democracy.
It's okay.
They have socks.
Oh, what does it change?
What does giving socks do to a dude?
All right.
Inimini-inimani-mo, catch a tiger bato.
If you holler, let him go.
Inimini-inimani-mo.
All right.
It's democracy.
Oh, I can split them up.
All right.
I guess none of you guys are turning into weebs.
Goodbye, dude.
We killed two of you off.
one to into a weed but i forgot honestly oh this might not
be good for me okay they're not okay i saw snakes on the
other side so i got a little worried but it's okay our dudes
are okay anything but a weep all right i mean you can grab
another zombie dude along the way chest set up a bomb
damaging nearby enemies enemies split among them you know
okay let's go all dudes wait uh all dudes can 15% toughness.
Let's grab that.
Let's just grab everything possible.
Poor rattlesnakes.
I am afraid of the rattlesnakes because these guys were
crazy hard.
So I'm not gonna fight the rattlesnakes.
Like I don't trust my dudes against a fight with a snake.
Like apparently my dudes do not know how to suck yet.
They're not at that point of their relationship yet, guys.
These dudes are still like, you know, um, They're still on
the first base with each other, guys.
These dudes, you know, they're like new dudes, you know.
They're still working on their relationships with each
other.
Let's see.
The Ghost 2 Grants targets for 5 seconds.
All dudes gain 2% when a dude heals through.
And it's 20% chance the zombie dudes gain.
I'm renewing you by this effects.
I'll do Ritual Dagger.
chill dagger.
You know what?
Dude, let's try it.
Let's try the snakes.
What's the... Oh my god.
Okay, these snakes are a lot easier.
Never mind.
I should have trusted my dudes.
Holy shit, that dude exploded.
Yeah, new gen dudes gotta train.
Yeah.
The dude whisperer will train them.
Oh, you're out with another assassin.
Whoa, dude.
You gotta... The food dude arrived.
You gotta a lot of hungry dudes in this here, ranch.
Look at him.
They're just skin and bones and other stuff too, probably.
Jessica, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm gonna read for it.
What, dude?
We're just dudes being dudes.
Bro, where are you?
Bro, are you homophobic or some shit?
Bro can't be a bro?
Brophobic?
Um, anyway, you prophobic, bro?
Anyway, if you got cash, I could cook up a nice meal for one
of your dude types and make him stronger for the rest of the
run.
All right, let's grab the chili dog.
20% and 5% crit chance.
We should give it to the ghost dude, right?
Yeah.
We want to give crit chance more to the ghost.
Wow, dude, I totally kissed his name.
All right, prove it.
Kiss the dude right now.
You prophobic, bro?
Okay, yeah, brofubs just be jealous, dude, yeah.
Alright, three hogs.
I don't even need to check it.
I know my bro's got it.
What's this game?
How many dudes, bro?
How many dudes?
We gotta get more assassins.
Alright, round 30.
Damn, round, bro, my dudes have stamina.
Round 33.
uh we'll start to seek out injured dudes and dash to them
who who's they'll need to find an injured dude to do that
bro no promo guys like all the promo all right let's grab
grab another zombie dude oh shit my dude's return get in
here dude Oh my god.
They're all here.
They came back from the dude whisperer.
Alright, let's see.
Should we get orbital trooper?
Do we need more democracy or more assassin?
Guys.
For the creed or democracy?
More democracy?
Alright.
Democracy time.
Dude games for every dude of the same family.
Fuck it, let's go.
Oh, shit, I didn't see this.
In the first direct damage, the samurai dude, after dashing,
he kills.
Damn it!
Bro!
Bro, why did you tell me to read, bro?
Bro, this is your dude.
Dude.
You could have told me to read, bro.
Bro, dude.
Dude, you didn't even look, dude.
Bro, how the fuck was I?
supposed to look no dude how is i supposed to know that's on
you bro how many horses can i do to take in a fight right in
a fight open your eyes bro bro i can't bro it's so hard to
read when i'm looking into your eyes bro no bro no homo
though all right let's Oh, nice.
Dude, thanks.
And a 444 little ducks.
That's a lot of ducks.
No promo, though.
Can't stop looking at your eyes, bro.
Alright, nice.
Coward.
Dude, you've got a really sweet pile of cash.
You're lucky for you.
I've got a business opportunity that's totally legal what
type of business you get you ask money that's what i can
double your investment in just 15 rounds what do you say
friendo what a mix up you're not baller package because we
ball in that's right we ain't no bro we let it ride that's
my bro motto all in all right let's grab We'll just have
like 80 orbital strikes at once at this point.
Just send the missile from Earth into Earth.
Use those taxpayers' money for good.
Like, what else are we doing with that money anyway?
Bro, oh shit, bro.
The dude type of the enemy Ross Imli taunts up to...
That would have been so good, bro.
But don't worry, we're playing the log game.
Guys, we're doing the log.
game this will be worth it later oh shit i feel like this is
like uh i'm looking at the stock market right now oh shit
bro my zombies it's okay it's okay bro it's okay to come
back uh oh all right we might need more healers now gains 20
percent okay we actually need the shrunken oh all dudes oh
we all dudes keen 40% cleave.
Wait, we gotta get that.
Okay, you found a trinket stash.
Low key getting cooked, bro.
Riz, dudes adjacent to the wielder on the roster and gain 1%
crit chance and 1% evasion for every two wielders.
What's a wielder?
Max HP, cleave.
What the fuck's a wielder?
The wielder.
Oh.
Oh, to whoever holds this.
It's whoever.
Purdue on that.
Oh, who it's equipped on.
Oh, I see.
The wielder gains 40% run speed.
Every four seconds dashes.
If we're.
Oh, cut off George.
Damn.
For every 25 feet of the wielder travels.
He gained a stacking 1% power.
I don't.
Riz.
I feel like Riz.
either Riz or Jorts alright dude do we want Jorts will work
well on the teleport yeah I was thinking about that I think
the Jorts will look great on the samurai and I guess like
it'd be good for the
let's see yo you look great on those Jorts dude bro you can
pull it off bro you can definitely pull off Jorts, bro.
Jorts for the dude, bros.
Okay, but we gotta put it on.
Alright, I don't...
Okay, Sam, Riz on... Who do we put Riz on, though?
We need the crit.
You're right.
Ah, but... Okay, but then, like...
Who would be next to the... Who would be next to the ghost
dudes, though?
Okay.
What do we put?
Do we put on the troopers?
Rizz up the trooper dudes?
Or the zombie dudes?
Zombies in.
Oh, we'll move Ghost up then.
Alright, we'll give it to we'll give it to the trooper
dudes.
Bro, you're gonna be so rizzed up, bro.
Bro, the ladies are gonna fucking... Oh, there you go.
Bye.
Don't worry.
No bruise left behind!
Alright, so we move.
Why don't we...
There you go.
I think that's good.
Nope, bro.
Left behind, bro.
Alright, let's fight 172 Gs.
I didn't even realize we were like...
We like...
That was a boss, but...
No wonder we had these poor zombies who got fucked up.
More heals or assassins?
The lady's gonna love democracy, bro.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Bro, those ladies, they're not going to be able to handle
all that democracy.
Until you got a discerning eye for rare relics.
Well, I told you I could get my hands on relics that some
were considered unnatural.
Don't take me 10 rounds to get my hands on some
unconventional relics for you to choose from.
For a fee, of course.
Come on, dude, you ain't going to find relic these on your
own.
Bro, that's a deal, bro.
That shit is nuts.
All in, bro.
Got new cryptocurrency for me to invest in.
That's totally not a rug pull.
Bro, I trust you, bro.
We were in a frat together.
You ain't gonna fuck with me.
Oh, shit.
Another regular, sweet.
Another regular dude.
All right.
We got beat up a fucking cat.
Bro, ain't no way, bro.
We in a frat, bro.
We did our pledges together.
there bro ha cha cha trust the bro your life savings exactly
bro I don't think like I feel like I'm looking at an actual
like I'm looking at a graph right now alright let's see
another orbital strike oh shit okay look we're stalking the
merchant dude shop now cost $25 less alright these are Oh,
re...
Oh, the first restock is always free.
I'll grab a loyalty card then.
I might have this.
God damn it!
Alright.
Zombie dude gains 20% health.
God damn it.
That's fine.
I'll lay out my anger on these goddamn ducks.
They don't know what's gonna fucking hit them.
Alright.
Let's see.
more heals lend me your spray and pray and when did I get
that let me do I have those oh my god I do I don't even
remember having these in my pockets bro when did I get these
got some nice rail there I know we're fine okay they'll they
want spray and pray has 25% chance to cause an ectoplasm
explosion implying 20% vulnerability
he damaged surrounding forever oh we should get the zombie
wait can't get both oh i can do both bucket let's go i think
it's worth it if i can get both of them yeah we got plenty
of stuff it's good equivalent exchange oh my god that horse
is running away damn no survivors he's like mercy i was like
no mercy killing here All in!
You live a bro, you die a bro!
Alright, nice.
We're going fast now.
Alright, my...
It's not boss fight.
Alright.
7-6, dog side, rest.
No.
Only death battles, dude.
Many dudes enter the circle.
Oh, dudes, leave the circle.
Okay.
I think we have enough ghosts.
Oh, shit.
We'll give one.
We'll let one be a weave.
We'll let him live his dream out.
Go live your life, bro.
We'll send one out to Japan.
Just you, bro.
But only you.
Don't say I don't do nothing for you, bro.
Okay, Living Will.
When any dudes get knocked out, the 10 most injured roster
dudes are healed.
The zombie dude's skin.
20%.
Oh, okay, we're going to grab that.
And then we'll grab Living Will just in case.
And then, ah, it's okay.
We make money to spend money.
Oh, my God.
That's a...
I'm crazy.
They're starting to drop now.
Dude got a free trip.
Japan bro it's not I'm jealous all right get more okay hair
trigger when the trooper deals attack damage he has a free
percent chance to fire a laser bolt at a random enemy doing
direct damage for 1% of his attack okay oh it me grants two
burn phones and splitting headache uh no hair oh wait this
guy it's like shoot first ask questions later uh dude's
teleported by burn phone scheme for 30% chance.
Let's see.
Two Skeletons are summoned when you taunt, so I pierce it
into the underworld and summons a Skeleton with one second.
Oh!
Wait, this is really good.
Wait, both of these are really good.
Because I have a lot of zombies that taunt.
Oh!
I can have unlimited Skeletons.
I can summon the Skeletons from the Netherworld.
Oh, I don't know.
They can bounce.
That's true.
But, but, dude, more dudes is more.
It's better.
But laser is cooler.
DPS or dudes?
Oh, the, oh, okay.
I'm just going to, I'm closing my eyes.
Oh shit, okay, never mind.
That didn't work.
Which one was this?
Okay, I can't, it doesn't work like that.
It, it, it, uh,
bro, I'm here for whatever you choose, dude.
Magic versus sign.
God, you're right.
Democracy, bro.
All right, let's kill these crabs.
All right, bro.
I chose democracy.
This better be worth it.
all right i mean you might as well grab more democracy i
told you i'd be back take your pick dude wait you only one
one dude takes fatal damage he has a 15 chance 25 now gets
converted into temporary help all dudes get all dudes gain
five percent evasion all right fight those birds birds are
scary though um crows are a menace in canada You need more
ghosts.
Grab more assassins so we can...
Oh, shit, my vest!
Bro, I knew you wouldn't hold out on me, bro.
That's why you always invest in crypto.
JK slash JK slash JK.
Please don't cancel me.
But invest in your bro's crypto.
Not just any regular crypt.
Right.
I like how the horses are just running away like they're
doing plays I just went to the wrong ranch I just stumbled
into the wrong ranch I didn't mean to be here because
they're not even fighting back the dokey coin guys you still
grab grab your own dokey coin now not a scam bro you'll
trust my crypto
Pumpkin latte Reduce the price by We don't need the all
dudes gain Okay, we gotta grab that And then the free
restock The third dude type Earn gains 10 One, two, three
Okay, we gotta We'll move ghost dude here And then Oh Shit,
all my dudes Okay, wait, I can buy both of them Okay, watch
this Um Um
um wait wait wait wait how do i okay move
move what can i move you i got a grip bro it'll be fine yeah
exactly okay there you go um oh my god why is this so hard
okay there we go There you go.
There you go.
See?
Nothing to worry about.
This is the one with the crypto.
Crypto.
Not crypto.
Crit chance, right?
Okay.
It was the trooper, right, that I gave it to?
I don't remember.
Because I wanted to give it the ghost crit chance as well.
Because I'm trying to get... Oh, shit.
What was it?
It's spooky, dude.
What did I buy again?
Oh, my gosh.
I've lost track.
I bought so many stuff.
I'm sort of...
I'm getting confused, dude.
I'm getting so confused, bro.
I...
Oh, third slot.
Okay.
Bro.
Okay, and then...
Bro, I got it.
Bro, bro.
I got it, bro.
Bro, I got it.
There you go.
We got it, bro.
We figured it out.
Alright.
Nice.
Bro cracked the code, bro.
I've done it.
Okay, I'm there.
We need more poison anyway.
Alright, let's fight it.
Alright, I'm not even worried.
I ain't a word I got tanks for days Tanks and heals for days
I got it Who said I can't do math Uh I don't remember what
the samurai even has Not gonna lie
Do we want democracy or webs Bro ain't stopping no bro
that's a dangerous species bro well maybe if they uh jacked
up a little bit more they wouldn't be so they wouldn't be so
in danger that's on them
all right let's go get that out of here uh grab more zombies
invest all in bro you've been here for me since the
beginning bro
bro they feed a gorilla bro how many dudes this many dudes
oh my god one silver back oh wait we're at the boss fight
now wait no no we're not next fight two werewolves they
always ask where never never howl all right never who oh my
god oh i gotta say nothing um we got assassin or samurai
harambe no no one never one that really knew what happened
to harambe Not when, Wolf.
I can't watch.
Assassin?
Alright.
Let's see.
What's this?
We'll buy this just because I have it anyway.
Universal Healthcare.
Hey, guys, you want to look at it?
25% piercing.
Alright, let's go, dude.
Okay, I do have, like, items if I need to.
If I need to use it.
And I don't think I do.
Jesus, that one samurai is getting fucked up.
Surround him!
He can't take us on!
Oh, shit.
One zombie got fucked up, though.
Alright.
I'll grab more ghosts.
Brass, knuckles, half full glass, and...
Oh, dang.
Brass, all dudes gain 30%.
This bonus decays by every second until it runs out.
When a dude takes a fail, it damages.
25% chance to shock a nearby enemy or 100% of his DPS and
then survives by teleporting away.
Oh, wait, this is good.
I feel like the oh dang button would be the best.
Because then you get TP away and get healed up later.
Yeah, that button's broke.
This literally what it's like when you make us vote for
things on membership streams.
I miss.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, bro, this is socialism.
For two seconds, the wielder grants temporary help for 25%
to an injured roster, dude, for...
Bro, okay, but I still think you guys can pull off the
George's, though.
I...
Oh, dang.
Socialism?
Guys, I don't think we're ready for that.
But what about the George's, though?
Who was it that TP's?
Was it a samurai or the assassin?
I don't remember.
George over socialism.
Yeah.
Bro, I don't think we're ready for the weave.
We got to give the no health care.
No socialism.
Let's give socialism to the zombies.
But guys, the George snow.
The George.
George!
What about this George?
Alright.
Scrub.
I'm another zombie.
Today's matchup is against 13 alpha wolves and two unicorns.
I think we're alpha enough, bro.
Yeah, that's, let's go.
Let's fucking go.
I think we can take them on.
Bro.
Oh, shit.
That's right.
Keep blowing them up.
Oh, my God.
We got this, bro.
We're so alpha.
We're, if there's 80 of us, the alpha-ness is combined.
It's accumulation of pure alpha.
Domination, bro.
There's two, three wolves inside of you, bro.
grappling dummy all enemies gain 5% chance when an enemy
misses a target dude has a 3% chance to strike uh mouthguard
all dudes gain 5% deflection when dude deflects has 10%
chance to block all dudes gain 2% regeneration when a deal
it heals um shit bro i don't know they're all good they're
all like defense kidded too i'm sure you get bro like bro
this is all good for the gains too.
Ice path for the vibe.
No, we're not talking about in real life, bro.
I'm talking about in this.
Yeah, all these are good because they're all like for the
gains, though, bro.
They're all like, bro, imagine our routines gonna go so fire
with any of these.
Like, damn, bro.
Can we get so many resistance?
Yeah.
Bro, we can't let's have them grinding their teeth bro but
bro imagine us all us dudes in the nice path bro together
true bro all right let's grab let's grab the ice path
all right nice dummy for practicing hugs all right more
democracy 108 Canadian beast right here
Our legs touch when we're getting that ice bath together.
We'll grab a samurai just because we haven't done a samurai
yet.
What the fuck is that?
We'll let this tiger in here.
Well, we killed the last remaining tiger in this world.
Oh, yes, it's George.
We gotta grab that for the George.
sign me up.
Uh, we're gonna buy that.
I'm just gonna grab that just to see what we could have got.
Send that meteor in!
Oh, I just got them.
Oh, never mind.
I didn't realize it was just me calling it.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
Well, I have, like, an emergency meteor just in case.
Grab another ghost.
Let me...
Wailing flesh.
A ghost dude.
What did I get?
Samurai dude gains 50% cleave, 3% fucking just get in there.
It's fine.
My dudes are okay.
Oh shit.
When did I lose two samurais?
Oh no, they weaved up too hard.
They went too hard.
I didn't even realize they weaved out.
I mean, I have so many heals.
I'll do it later.
I think they'll be fine.
If I have to, I will heal them.
I think it's fine.
I don't need to use any items yet.
Bro, we min-maxing.
Alright.
We'll grab another zombie.
Keep going.
Yo, what round we are?
We're almost there, bro.
We're almost there.
You can't kill a ghost.
Where are you going to go to?
Super Hell?
You know what?
Get another ghost in here.
All right, it's time.
It's time for our favorite round, guys.
Nice.
Of course it's just rats.
Round.
Oh my god, look at this.
Look at all these rats we killed.
All right, claim reward.
Um...
Grab another zombie.
Oh, shit, another regular dude.
I haven't seen a regular dude in so long.
When he deflects, he gained 5%.
All dudes gained during battle per unconscious dude.
I don't think we have conscious dudes to use that on.
Oh, my God.
If I...
God, damn it.
If only pro, can you lend me like $10?
Like, each of...
If every pro lends me $10.
I can clone myself.
Bro, I know.
I thought we fit all the regular dudes in the zombies.
I thought we turned them on the zombies.
When did that happen?
Enemy grants two pocket dice and reduces their price.
When Bowser, the dude type at the end of the millitons up to
five enemies.
Bro.
Okay, but we need...
Okay, when that summary dude arises that he gains an
independently stacking...
Okay.
I'm going to grab the, yeah, I'm going to grab the Katana
Sharper because I don't think I can, I can readjust, because
I need Ghost to be the third slot, so no matter, and I could
put Trooper dudes in, yeah, I can't, I can't rearrange this,
alright, four big Vs.
Alright, bro, it's the killer, the killer wasp are back!
Like, how fast the killer wasp thing came and went.
You know, I thought the killer wasp thing would be more
dangerous than what it was.
Okay, we gotta give the pretzels to the ghost.
10%, 15.
Alright, I'm gonna give the baguette to the ghost.
Oh, I can't.
Wait, what do we give then?
Yeah, in America, like, there...
At one point, there were killer wasps or something for,
like, a month, and then, like, it just...
I guess we killed them off?
Like, we sent in some dudes, and now they're gone?
Like...
Or should we give...
Wait, max HP to the zombie?
You're right.
I'll give it to the zombies.
Right?
Yeah.
I guess we killed them off.
We sent him some dudes to handle it.
Who would have thought?
That's how it goes.
Alright, goodbye.
What did I even kill?
Oh, a werewolf.
We'll grab more...
Samurai.
Yeah, bro!
Thanks for the crit bro, bro!
God, I knew I could count on you.
I always knew I could count on my bro to invest in some crit
bro.
Alright, let's kill the werewolf.
Oh, shit.
The regular dude.
Goodbye, everybody, dude.
Who brought- Hey, who invited this, bro?
This dude here.
All right, so in round 74.
Bro, who invited this bro here?
To the moon.
I don't even know if, like, my run is good or not.
Like, am I supposed- Is my run supposed to- My first run
supposed to go this night?
Or- I can't tell.
I can't tell.
Ooh, I found some nice crap.
Forest field.
Emilia, two bottled lightning and reduces.
Okay, we're going to get the forest field.
And then we'll restock.
Emilia gains two dude juice.
All considered.
Getting us to heal.
Oh, we've got to get the sewing kit.
You just have a very good...
Like, am I endless again?
Is this endless mode again?
Okay.
You're just him, bro.
How many rounds is there?
I feel like there's so many dudes.
Bro, my dude ranch is expanding.
We're back to yesterday's problem.
Oh, grab more.
Oh, nice.
I can have them back now.
Like, I'm running out of rows!
I'm on my third row now!
Oh, these wolves are tanky, though.
I only killed like five of them.
Oh, never mind!
Now they're gone!
Never mind!
We're gonna make sure!
We're gonna make them extinct!
My highest is 100.
I got to as 117.
Alright, we'll grab more ghosts, dude, just to live forever.
Bro, I'm all in, bro.
You know it, bro.
You know I could count on you, bro.
Oh my god.
He doesn't know that every round the U.S.
is forced to burn down parts of California and keep the
killer organs at bay.
Wait, is that true?
The thing is, I can't tell if that's true or not.
I don't know if you're lying, Ninja.
Because that just seems like something America would do.
Like anything is possible in America now.
Oh shit, another irregular dude.
I can't tell anymore.
Freshies, no!
Bro, I guess we're not changing our bed sheets for another
year.
I'm sorry, bro.
That's the checks out.
Like, you would think that that could be a lie.
But then we legitimately built a killer robot for search and
rescue.
Can't tell no more.
What is real or not?
Oh, shit.
A ghost can die?
What do you mean?
Okay.
Vault grants return 100% increased payout after winning a
battle.
Okay.
The first direct damage to Samurai Duel.
He heals for 15%.
He gains a stack every two seconds.
Teddy do a temper health for less than 25% of his health.
HP would siphon some From other dudes who have extra spare
until he reaches Uh, oh shit What do we get?
Yeah, just turn the bed sheets inside out Bro Yeah, we
clearly made a son And then they had like, and I read more
about it So you know how I showed a picture about like where
you can Deactivate it by shooting or stabbing It?
So in case the robot Goes rogue and goes Into the wrong
hands They have a kill switch Like like why do we need to
put the killer robot has a kill switch in case it's in the
wrong hands like what the fuck like
money or cool sword okay we'll grab money when the wielder
lands a critical he gains a stacking 5% the wielder gains a
step for every second each wielder has 24% chance to
teleport around Although I'm on the roster to a random
distinct dude on enemy and granite.
Ooh.
We give him a laser pointer, shovel, or a glass cannon.
Oh, wait.
No, not the glass cannon.
Guys, we can't.
We can only give this to, like, two of our guys.
So, the wielder gains a stacking 20% cleave during battle
for every unconscious dude.
Um, I don't know.
Pointer Whoever is above the samurai Who do we give it to
Assassin's suit
We can't give it to the trooper dude Because can we Wait Can
we give more than one item
Can more than one dude hold an item or Well they have
pockets Dudes have pockets I guess not I guess these dudes
don't have pockets dude what the fuck bro are you i mean to
be fair he's wearing shorts
only one trinket don't worry yeah dude you got two hands
dude i thought you dudes love pockets do we give this i
guess i'll give this to the assassin
yeah to be fair one is wearing pockets nope dude a left
behind Wait a minute.
That ghost have legs.
Bro, wait a minute, bro.
Are you trying to...
What the fuck?
The regular dude died so fast.
Wait a minute, dude.
I'm starting to have a feeling that that ghost might not be
a real ghost.
Hmm.
I'm starting to suspect...
Oh, sure.
Okay, let's go.
Oh, the ghost is parked, dude.
Stupid.
Are you fucking stupid, dokey?
He's parked, dude.
Okay, I'm gonna roblox.
I feel like we need more orbital dudes.
Random thingy was super chat.
Thank you.
Attention, dokeybird.
For your services to the dude army, our leader, the dude of
the...
Dudes himself has authorized me to make you one of us.
I hereby dubbed Doki, dude.
Welcome to the Dudes, dude.
Dude, I've been a member since conception, bro.
Well, you gotta read on your bro manual.
Oh, shit, another free dude.
Bro, I was one of the founding dudes.
If anything, I just gotta renew my membership.
My member bro.
My brovership.
More heals.
That should be another regular dude.
Assassin dude gains an each stack toxin out applies.
When dude takes damage after this he gains 100% cleave.
Okay, we'll grab this for the assassin and I'll grab that.
Oh shit, that's a polar bear.
Now we know why some animals are...
Oh shit!
What the fuck?
Okay, that had to be a boss fight.
Because what the fuck happened to my dudes?
Okay, let me snake oil.
Fuck it.
Go wild.
I think I can...
That had to be a...
Yeah, that had to be a boss fight.
Because what the fuck happened?
Oh, wait, the dude whisperer is...
coming.
It's fine.
I can, if need to, I can send in a meteor and then set off
the next extinction, global extinction.
If I have to, of course.
Okay, we'll grab another, okay, do we have enough, we'll
grab another assassin just for the poison stacks.
Oh my god, there's just too many people wandering around, so
I can't tell if they're okay or not.
Okay.
Everything's fine.
I just feel like maybe if I just put more poison in, it
should work eventually.
More guns, maybe more democracy.
Democracy always works, you know?
Oh, shit.
Me to right!
Oh, heal everybody!
Oh, my god, what happened?
What?
What the fuck happened?
I thought democracy always works.
What?
What happened?
All right.
Let's come back.
What?
A crab is...
Bro!
There's a turtle with a shotgun?
These are weak against crap.
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
Oh my god, what's happening?
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna have to start buying Dude Juice now.
I'll send more Ghost in.
Okay, we're gonna...
We're gonna grab another...
We're gonna grab a Dude Juice here.
uh yeah all right let's see all dudes gain trooper dudes
when you he use the gains and okay we're gonna grab the
helmet oh thank you oh oh man oh man all right we're gonna
make sure everybody's back on track uh i need i need more
max hp okay we're gonna focus on max hp right now Oh, my
God.
My God.
Meteor.
All right, here we go.
All right, there we go.
We're just going to send.
All right.
Okay, this is bad.
Oh, this is really bad.
Okay, we need max HP.
Oh, an airport.
They use super chat.
Thank you.
When a dude gets thrown, he gains 100% chance.
all dudes gain when a roster dude attacks he gets us the
next number in the nuclear code when all numbers all enemies
take oh shit we gotta we gotta what's the roster dude guys
we gotta start nuking things i'm feeling lucky tonight all
right all right we're gonna battle the rattlesnakes i don't
trust my dudes no more all right we have we're gonna we're
gonna do the round snakes i i'm a little worried about
eventually one of the numbers will work
all right grab the zombies okay groups of dudes to a
location of your choosing all right i told you i'll be back
every time the merchant dudes invent there is 25 chance he
gets charmed and you're like nope evades against all dudes
gain temporary health equal to six percent of their every
last until it is depleted I feel like mana collector or jazz
flute all the dudes are punching in the codes really really
do we do we like jazz or do we want to collect mana yeah I
feel like mana might be the most I'm really scared about I'm
gonna go with this right now because my dudes are not okay
my dudes are not okay right now we need more max HP at the
moment yeah all right all right we have an HP issue oh shit
cha-ching baby all right we'll do this like HP is not an
issue for us right now so sorry not HP I don't like money is
not an issue We invested for the Crypt Bros.
So we'll just beat people up.
George Sir Ghost, guys.
George Sir Ghost.
Which one?
Two codes.
Bro, bro.
Two codes, bro.
George Sir Ghost.
Ghost?
George?
bro what about ghost with jorts
all right ghost dead oh shit nice i got my people back okay
most of my people have respawned okay let's see train dudes
return merchant i'm just gonna go with i'm gonna not risk it
right now so we're just gonna go here I don't want to risk
anything.
Because we already have a lot of money at the moment, so
it's fine.
I'll get more ghosts.
Nice.
We got my dude juice.
My dude takes damage that drops his.
He gains half full glass.
Brings his HP.
He heals for 15% of...
Okay.
We'll do this.
And then we'll buy...
Um...
We'll grab...
rage bait too and then
any dude with no dudes will get knocked out teleported any
dude with no dudes near him will get knocked out teleported
to a new location near a random dude what okay when dude
gets knocked out all dudes gained for the rest of this if I
can okay I feel like dog tag would be good I don't know
about this.
Should we get the warp gate deck?
Is it good?
Is it worth it?
I mean, yeah, you're right.
It combos.
All right, let's try.
Oh, shit.
Why did I try with this?
Why?
Wait a minute.
Why did I try with the hardest, guys?
I did not think this through.
I forgot I don't need.
I don't need like...
Okay, we're going to revive our bros after this.
I was like, I don't need that much money right now.
Alright, we'll grab more ghosts.
And then we'll revive some dudes.
Who thinks, bro?
money so we could just fight the regular guys honestly i
think by the time we get oh come on we're almost there the
nuclear options set the nuke in oh we were so close the
codes we have the assassin okay we're trying do the feral
hug because we have lost a lot of ghosts
samurais are really squishy they are okay grab more of this
all right we have let's see 12 13 25 26 okay we just have
two we're just missing two so it's fine for now we don't
have to use our restore heals for anything yet why these It
is getting harder, though.
Round 99.
Okay.
Grab Ghost.
If the first hit...
If the first hit deals, stashing the heals for 50%, we'll
grab that.
Power Siphon.
Okay.
Okay, we gotta grab this.
And then we're gonna grab Dew Juice.
And I'm gonna restock again.
And then we'll grab medical, the nanobots.
The nanobots, bro.
The nanobots.
All right.
One baby.
Two dudes spawn far apart from each other.
All right.
Okay.
Let's find out.
All right.
I'm going to send the bomb.
The meteorite first.
And then we'll see how this goes.
I do have.
a million lightnings okay this is possible don't worry bro
regen time bro alright nice okay the items work alright okay
grab more alright there you go the toddler died nanomachines
son enemies cannot attack until 1% 5 seconds oh wait you
know we might have need universal health care wait shit okay
stasis cube or universal health care 1.5 seconds I don't
know that's enough stasis cube is huge we might
pro the universal yeah we don't need oh it's like the do
type at the top of your roster gains 30% attack power If I
don't get that in Tuesday.
Yeah, we don't...
Yeah, exactly.
We don't take damage if they can't do damage, bro.
Bro.
What was your problem again, Doki?
Fine!
3% have a small body difference between the count and the
most prevalent dude type.
That's too much information.
We're gonna give you a folding chair.
That's too much info.
I'm gonna give him a folding chair.
Yeah.
All right.
This should be fine.
Oh my god.
This is fine.
There's a lot of stuff going on on my screen right now.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there's so many.
So many sounds.
Guys, it's not too loud, right?
I hope it's not too loud, guys.
Everything is red, dude.
Wait, is it all boss battles now?
What?
So much is happening.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Every... Just everything!
Kill him off!
Survive.
Yeah, just survive.
Can we do that?
It goes soon.
I don't know how long, how long it takes for them to fucking
rest.
Okay.
We'll have five, six, seven, eight.
Oh, wow.
I'll just, I'll use that now.
Just in case.
And I'll use the lightning.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
What
happened?
Oh, this is bad.
This is bad.
This might be GGs.
Oh, I sure...
to keep buying.
I didn't know there was going to be no more bro juice bro.
Oh, this is so bad.
Oh, dude, juice.
We need every help we can get.
Oh my god.
Dude, just rest, dude.
Okay.
That's all I could use
One The G-O-A-T Goat
That's the most Juice I could buy
The goat
Oh my god Oh
my god Oh my god Get back It's all nuclear objects
We needed to go!
Is it there no?
We were so close!
That's why he's the goat.
Are you so close to dying too?
Oh my god.
We have to kill the goat.
We...
Oh my god.
That was so close.
The moment the ghost...
Yeah.
Oh, I should have grabbed the stasis cube.
I really...
I should have.
I thought about it.
But I was just like...
Oh, no.
I should get the other one.
Oh, that was so...
close the cube bro the cube our team was so good yeah that
was yeah the dudes did great my this was the time if I
needed the nuclear launch code it was then it was was dead.
Alright.
Do we do random or we should try new dudes?
We should try new dudes.
I want to try new dudes.
Um.
Earn gold star by tier one.
Two tier one.
Alright.
We gotta do new dudes bro.
If only we had the launch codes.
I let it ride and it didn't ride.
I don't understand back to beating up kids I guess I don't
oh my god alien dudes he beams a random dude and immediately
above him on the forcing him to dash the enemy
what oh I might like just oh wait but I could get ninjas
ninja is strong so grab ninjas then all right get in here
ninjas all right we're gonna try ninja out it's like a
samurai with extra steps true uh all right nice you found a
relic winning dude gets knocked out the 10 most injured
roster dudes are healed free shuriken he gains oh
wait okay ah which is better bonfire Or sharpen.
We need a healed dude, though.
We do need a healed dude.
Star is not good.
I don't want reroll yet.
Sounds good for late game.
Alright, poor little rats.
Let's go.
Yeah, because I don't know...
Oh shit.
Oh my god, he's living by a thread right there.
We need a heal, dude.
My deal is he has, when it done to steal, he injects a
random...
Nova King for...
I actually watched...
You know what's funny?
I watched Nova King yesterday with the...
What was the name?
Jack Wade?
That shit was so fucking hardcore.
Oh my god.
That...
I watched Nova King yesterday.
And oh my god.
That shit was...
I did not expect how gory that shit.
I mean, it is R-rated.
But it's basically like...
A movie about a guy who cannot feel pain or anything was
born with a genetic disorder where you can't feel any pain.
And he's out there trying to save his girlfriend from, like,
bank robbers.
And he, like, kills several people.
And it's, like, fucking wild.
I'll re-world this.
Palette!
Oh, my God!
Ghost dude!
Wait, we have to put Ghost dude back in.
It's a wild movie.
The inverse law of ninja strength.
The more ninjas are, the weaker they are.
Ninja.
Jack, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Chakran.
Ghost dude.
Get back in here.
He lives.
Ghost dude lives.
Oh, goodbye regular dude.
We don't need you.
We have ghost dude and ninja dude.
Grab another ghost dude.
Okay, I'm going to start getting...
I'm going to start stockpiling dude juice.
Now that I know...
Now that I know, I need to start stockpiling dude juice.
I don't trust myself anymore.
Kill him!
Ghost dude!
Deal!
Oh, we got another ghost dude.
We're going to start...
We're going to fight babies right now.
Just because I don't know.
Yeah, I got to start...
We are at the dude ranch.
We gotta start farming dudes.
Like, why am I buying...
Why am I buying dude juice?
When I have dudes to farm...
Like, I should be the supplier of dude juice.
At my dude ranch.
Like, what is the ranch for?
We need a tank, though.
Yeah, we should reroll.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Medic dudes?
Bro, I could have got Medic dudes.
This...
Oh, my God.
I got...
rosters to pretend every time he deals in bro i got two
healers but then paladins are good too
oh all right paladin dudes all right all right let's try
let's see this out let's check out the paladin dude bro he's
so big holy shit that guy is fucking massive oh yeah He
knows he's big.
He fucking knows, too.
He's like, yeah, check me up, bro.
Do you want ninjas or ghosts?
Dude, I just remember.
That's why you got violent.
Do I get ninja or ghost?
This will be the dragon run.
Ninja?
Alright.
That's true.
We do lack DPS.
Oh, 20% ninja piece.
I'm invisible.
for two seconds um when this nearby dude's gain oh shit but
i don't know dragon you choose this is gonna be the dragon
build you're gonna take me all the way to the end and take
me to the moon to the moon we go which one dagger smoke bomb
receptor this has 20 maxio
Dagger?
Alright, we'll go with dagger.
I'm gonna try and fight the big ones.
Get the big money early on.
Because it stacks.
Oh, my regular dude is back.
Why are you using that on the regular dude?
He doesn't deserve it.
He's just a regular man.
Alright, I think...
Alright, 2, 4, 5.
I think I'd last finance dude.
Wait, all he does is just give me money.
I mean, I guess.
But $3?
Just three dollars.
Money farm?
He got the criminal.
We get... I don't know.
I don't know what their special...
Or healer.
Aww.
Find that citizen as a Cuban.
Alright, we'll grab Viking then.
Do juice.
I've learned my ways.
I need as much do juice as possible.
I'll grab that.
Do type at the end.
Who do we want more max HP?
Paladins?
Because they are ghosts.
It should be paladin.
It should be the ghost, right?
Just because like...
Um...
Are they...
Paladins?
Alright.
We have it to the Paladins.
Just so they can tank more.
I wish I could speed this up a little bit more.
Grab another Viking and another...
Nice, sweet.
Alright.
I'm gonna grab one more ghost.
Like, if we get another ghost, I'll grab more ghosts.
Okay, Clem.
Pal- grabbing their Paladin.
I'm gonna gain two Dude Juice.
Oh!
You smell one.
You can knock out.
Okay, I'm grabbing you.
We need more Dude Juice.
I- I was like, I've learned the Dude Juice wins.
Yeah, I need like two times two or some shit.
I've learned.
dude juice we could have made it out we need the protein
okay um medallion when paladin takes fail damage blessing
folios and all paladin dudes gain a stacking bro put that
shit on my paladin bro stack that shit up okay grab more dps
too all right Grab that dude juice.
Smoke bomb.
Okay, all dudes getting life steals.
Always good.
I could restock and buy another dude juice.
I'm just stocking up on all the dude juice, guys.
Alright, nice.
We'll take another paladin.
And then we'll grab another ghost after that.
Just in case.
Yeah, I think I need another ghost just because my Vikings
are not doing so well.
one thing I would, because like each run is like two, I
realize each run is two hours long to get to a hundred.
Like so if we had two Xs, it would have been so much better.
Okay.
Wait, one more.
Oh, wait.
Time, dudes.
Okay, when he deals direct damage, he has 25%.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
Do we want, are any of these guys good?
Okay.
dentist time dudes or should we reroll
I just realized what time it is yeah
time dudes are good
I'm like no I'm copies of story 20% of all damage dealt by
is attached to after some time oh wait that's actually
really good that's like a damage sponge isn't it
I have two re-rolls I I don't get time, dude, or I re-roll,
guys.
What's better?
I'll re-roll.
Oh my god, he's back.
All right, cleric, assassin, or a troop, or democracy.
Cleric?
Is cleric good?
All right, we'll grab the cleric.
All right, that's our last dude.
Then we'll grab another ghost, and then I'll recruit another
cleric.
Actually, since it's also heals.
Yeah, I'm going to grab a cleric then, because they're both
heals.
Doctor, all DT is 20%.
Chance, gains, when he uses schemes.
All right, purple heart or mixtape?
I don't think I need cage tiger.
We're, oh my god, we're running 2-2-2, guys.
We have, we have 2-2-2.
what, this is guys, the reason we lost last run is because I
had one support.
GG's, we had one support.
That's the only reason.
We literally, it's because we had one.
GG's, we had one support.
That's why, guys, that's why we lost.
Oh, no!
Oh,
oh, I goodbye again.
Okay, I thought I'd lost it.
I clicked too fast.
I was clicking too fast.
Okay, all right, here we go.
I thought I fucked up, guys.
I'm glad if everything went okay.
Okay, this is a little scary, but I think we got it.
Yeah, I think we got it.
I think we got it.
This is 5.
This is so 5.
Okay, this is so 5.
That's okay.
I stocked up on Dujus for this.
Oh, okay.
I need more DPS.
I definitely...
I need more DPS right here.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I do not have enough DPS right now.
I need more DPS.
I need more ninjas and...
vikings okay ninjas all right here you go enters berserk
when he takes it mainly takes damage that drops is the
charge you now generates done every two seconds he okay
we'll grab this uh it will grab the gals suit who would go
best with uh who would go best with the suit guys
we definitely need more deep we're gonna try and focus on
vikings and ninjas after this ninja
ninjas okay yeah we might oh okay we're gonna fight the
little guys oh this is oh i should have healed my people oh
okay Um, no, that's okay.
Um, let's just...
There we go.
You're all okay now.
You're...
I think we might...
Oh!
Alright, we gotta stock up on some...
Alright.
Just go all in on the DPS right now.
grab more Vikings
okay ninja another sweet a regular dude okay I'm gonna fight
the little guys for now because we're sort of not doing so
great on DPS okay now we can okay this um
grab the and then another okay I think we can take on I
think we could take on the big boys now i think we can do it
i think we can do it yeah yeah all right all okay okay the
viking's dead but but we can do it now all right we'll grab
another healer just in case all right i'll give you guys
this and then we'll start we're start small again we'll
start small we're min maxing all right everything's good
We'll get another healer and then we'll go back to DPS So at
least like my DPS will be five
Yeah, I lend it out just because I'm thinking Oh wait, now I
have too many supports Okay, we'll grab another, okay,
another regular dude, that's five The dude whisper is coming
in soon We have the dude whisperer coming in He'll start
training our guys up claim reward or ninjas all right we'll
grab viking dude ninja uh and then i have another ninja oh
and then put that in here there you go that should be fine
do you think we can fight 274 ducks
we can do you think we can fight 274 ducks are my dudes good
enough all right let's try and find out oh my oh my god i
was a little worried with our paladins our paladins that was
oh that was a little too close.
Okay, I'm going to do thoughts and prayers, restock do
juice.
I'm a little worried now after I saw that.
It's a four dip.
Are we going to have more cleric?
I think our cleric is stronger than the ghost, for sure.
Doki loves DPS dudes per second, Semi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So in kit, all dudes have 15% chance on taking damage to
heal for, uh, when dude gets knocked out.
ninja dude I feel like sewing kit because it's all dudes
what's this food okay grab the leopard I just I'm a little
worried about my dudes right now I don't want them to just
calm down dudes grab a clear it oh what should I get where
should I feed them this is the dragon build I'm letting you
guys decide to build
cleave attack speed speed on cleric on
cleric or who yeah
all right all right yum yum you know what they're rats how
bad can it go our regular dude is very fucked up but that's
okay oh my god our paladin it's okay the rats how bad can it
go
they're like ninja i'm gonna get more ninja dudes 31 ravens
has 10 chance to apply it's fine they're just birds it
should be five oh my god oh oh they are doing a lot more
than i thought they were gonna do how bad did it go
apparently pretty bad oh yeah it's my dude's return Okay,
that's good.
Alright, we have...
Business dude's gonna come around here to make a legitimate
payment.
Alright, we're just gonna fight some babies now.
Since we have four dudes out of commission.
We definitely need more clerics.
No, I agree.
I'll grab more clerics after this.
Hey, no, look at that!
Look at that!
I said, Bob- Oh, I'm broke.
I got too invested in the dude juice.
Well, since we're...
I might as well buy another dude juice.
Since I can't afford anything.
I need all my dudes.
I'm going to wait for...
I don't want to risk it because I want my dudes to recover.
Okay.
Should I get Ninja or Viking?
I am going full in on Ninja right now.
Guys, which one should I get?
Ninja or Viking?
I miss my zombies, brother.
Zombies were so tanky.
Three cougars.
I'm going to keep going on the baby route right now.
I feel like my men, my dudes are like...
They're like early on pretty weak, but then I can build them
up to be like super good later.
Paladins are ninjas.
Vikings are better for bosses.
Maybe I'll stock up on Vikings later.
Ninjas are Ninja or Paladin?
Tank or DPS?
Yeah, late scaling dudes.
Paladins?
Yeah, I felt like my guys are better for late scale.
Okay.
Alright, Geese time.
Oh, they're all better now.
Alright, I want to save them all up for the final.
The final boss.
I'm too scared of my dudes dying.
I'm too scared.
I don't trust my dudes.
Okay.
Fucking best.
Since I don't have shop yet.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Paladins are vik- Hashtag, I didn't even say that.
Hashtag blessed.
Paladins are Viking.
Do we even need more paladins?
We do have eight right now.
Or Vikings for DPS.
You need DPS?
Alright.
Okay, one gorilla.
Oh my god!
Stop fighting!
Oh!
No, my cleric!
It's okay.
We still have other healers.
Oh, thank God I didn't.
Alright.
You know what I said?
We still have other healers.
It's okay.
At least I have my healers.
I have...
There's so much dude juice!
Alright, where is the scary one?
There we go.
It's okay.
I have so much dude juice for this occasion!
Okay, it's five.
There we go.
It's always the crabs!
Alright, and then book of life.
Uh, the ninja gains when he is...
Alright, mixtape or book of life, guys.
I don't think we...
I don't... I think we just go fuck the ghost now.
I think we gotta focus on cleric.
life all right team jersey gains nine to ten percent every
second the wielder gains five percent attack power stacking
up whoa this would be good with the cleric wouldn't it no
attack power or oh okay
or team jersey the rock where do i put for the rock though
Wait, who do I put on who?
Rock is so good.
Rock on Paladins?
Oh, I guess.
Yeah.
All right, we'll give it to the Paladins.
All right, Paladins.
Got new friends.
Paladins.
You got new friends.
All right.
We're gonna...
He'll get you a regular thing.
You can't get...
All right, we'll grab this.
We'll do the mini guys for now.
Like, some of our dudes need to recover.
Alright, claim rewards.
Ninja.
You know what?
I'm back to three.
That brings his HP below.
He can use 30% reflection.
Every second.
Alright, I would like that.
Oh, I like the oh dang button if we get that.
Or the Stasis Cube.
Fuck it.
Let's go.
That's actually pretty decent.
We'll fight all the small guys.
guys until we make enough no this is my second run i got
fucked up on the goat i literally lasted all the way to the
goat and he was one sliver of hp i'm so sad he was literally
one hp my zombie couldn't do it we're so close to all
right grab more heels oh my god dude juice oh my god My
prayers are answered.
We got nine.
That's it.
Now we fight 982 bees.
Oh, why did.
Oh, why did I decide to fight all those bees?
Oh,
my God.
I don't know why I decided to fight all those bees.
The stakes were big.
I got too excited.
Let's bring some of them back.
You don't have alien turkey.
I don't know.
I just...
I saw all those bees.
The turkey thing.
I don't know what game.
over me I just there was so many bees oh
that's good we'll grab we'll take those this is bad this is
pretty bad all right well I learned my lesson okay
paladin or clear it, guys.
Guys, I learned my lesson.
I saw a thousand bees.
I was like, I think...
I did, though!
I did thought I could win!
I saw so many bees!
And I was just like, yeah, I win.
Yeah.
You know what?
In fact, I think there's not enough bees.
I thought there would...
I thought it was too little.
I thought they should have added more bees.
Ghost or paladins.
Oh, yeah, so much paladins.
All right, we'll just keep going all in on paladins.
Oh, no.
I just...
I got too excited.
I just I wanted them to add more beans if anything
This might not be the dream team not gonna lie.
I sort of miss my OGs I think I've missed my I think I've
missed my dudes
Okay, I miss my day ones bro.
I really do I
I...
My day ones, bro.
Oh my
god.
Remember my dudes never died?
I missed those days.
Rashid's padded helmets.
Gains 1000.
all right we can only buy one which one do we want fresh
sheets or a padded helmet i feel like fresh sheets might be
better oh wait but this is only oh it's only for ghost um
maybe palleted helmet just for um sheets maybe sheets maybe
sheets or a helmet we can only all right sheets and then
we'll buy juke juice
all right
Jesus how did my clerical die oh
my god it's the snake it's oh my god oh
does no one tie
I don't even know This might be a dead run, guys Oh my I
didn't realize no one has taunt Guys, this might be a dead
run My first run was my best run Oh Do I get a tattoo or the
sword I don't know if I don't have taunts though That's the
thing or evasion
tattoo all right I'm gonna kill my dudes okay I'm hoping my
investment will come back soon because I really need money I
really all right
oh all right all right oh i'm not feeling so good about my
team no more all right warp deck all right force field warp
deck or i i don't know about power siphon i feel like either
warp deck or force field force field All right.
Okay, that's dessert.
Not a lot.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my Viking dude.
They're so fucked up right now.
But...
All right, cha-ching.
That's good.
Oh, I need that money.
I need that mule.
I need as many relics as possible.
right now.
Cha-ching!
Okay.
Cleric or ninja, guys?
DPS or support?
DPS or support, guys?
Cleric?
Okay.
Sweet.
I got two more paladins, too.
Oh, there's too many ravens.
I fucked up.
Bye.
Okay.
I grab a Viking for this.
Uh...
Oh, dude's game, yes.
And do juice.
And...
Uh...
Oh!
Do I clean?
I can...
Wait.
I can buy both.
Wait, I can buy both.
And I can buy do juice.
All the investment paid off.
That's good.
Yeah.
The investment paid off.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God for the investment I made.
Alright, Paladin or Ninja?
Oh, thank God.
Some AoE.
Finally.
Oh, my God.
Now I can fight 300.
Guys, now I can fight 100 bees.
Let's go.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's go fight a crab.
oh oh oh it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine i took the
risk i took the risk we're fighting the crabs i did i took
the risk you know what be cool in it okay i shouldn't uh not
don't do it not the crap we're so healthy we are so healthy
we are so healthy right now
I believed in my team so hard Okay, clear All right, all in
Okay But Fight the gorilla I like how I just have this one
regular guy that's just still hanging out He's just like Hey
guys Fancy seeing you guys here?
All right, Paladin or Ninja?
Tank or DPS?
I don't know which one we need more.
Oh, I'm just letting you guys think for me.
He's just the easy emotional support, dude.
Our emotional support, dude.
You see...
Probably more DPS, so ninja.
Let's see.
Alright, I'll do a ninja then.
Alright, 393.
Okay, we're gonna go.
We're just gonna fight the rats.
I don't know.
I don't know if I can trust my dudes right now.
There's a lot going in.
So many things going in.
Alright, we'll get Vikings.
I'm gonna still buy two Jews up, please.
and do juices because i don't have a lot of money okay oh
ghost down ghost down ninja down another ninja down but
that's okay we do have oh okay that's five one bear is the
bears are not down
Don't worry, don't worry, we can do this.
Don't worry, I believe.
They're almost dead.
The paladins are going strong right now.
It's okay.
The paladins, the tanker, the tank's tanking.
The tank is tanking.
We might need another ninja.
We should have got another paladins.
It's okay.
The tank is tanking, though.
Okay, do we need support or DPS?
You have chance for free items.
Take care, guys.
The tank's tanking.
Look, they're so happy.
DPS?
Oh, yeah.
All right, oh, hey, sweet.
A regular dude.
Oh, all right.
Um, I feel like Meteor is really strong.
Oh, wait, we gotta get the smelling salt just in case.
Furry 100 damage.
He heals a random injured roster, dude, for 15.
The wielder gains.
Alright, which one?
You guys pick.
You guys pick, guys.
Jersey on Clare.
Isn't Clare wearing something already?
Oh, no.
We'll grab, give it to him, then.
I didn't realize he wasn't wearing it.
Okay, we're sort of struggling a lot.
Oh, that's a lot of dead guys.
Okay.
All right, there we go.
That was a lot of dead guys.
I think we should be fine with that.
Yeah, they're just napping at it right there.
They're so tired.
They're just sleeping, guys.
Oh, my, my, my, my, my, my Viking.
Okay, in two rounds, we'll get our guys back at least.
Want to buy in?
Oh, no.
Maybe not.
My guys are not as tough as we think they are.
Guys, they're late-scale players.
They're late-scale.
They're late-scale, guys.
Don't worry.
They'll do so well.
I think these guys will be fine against Rally Snakes.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, don't worry.
They're so healthy.
You're so healthy right now.
Yeah, very late scale.
Very, very, very late scale.
They're just, they're very, very, very late scale game,
okay, guys?
Just very, very late.
They're so...
They're gonna make it.
Dookie Red Browse.
They're late, late, late scale.
Just you wait.
Oh, yeah.
Alright, Loki's arm.
Ooh.
When a dude lands after being thrown, he has a...
Okay, I feel like Loki's arm would be good.
I'll grab the...
and then what's my investment coming in okay over there oh
774 duck size i'm gonna grab the horses just because yeah i
think the vikings are doing really well right now oh yeah
their vikings are doing extremely well paladins then me was
this the ghost is has 25 applying takes field down he fully
heals and goes berserk disaffect oh wait this might be good
how many rounds 11 rounds, try 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9,
10, 11.
Okay, it's, okay, it comes back before.
I feel like I should do it.
I'm going to do it.
That'll be worth it.
That'll be so worth it.
Oh my god, oh my god.
It's okay, it's just a regular dude.
Alright.
More paladins.
We'll have so many Paladins.
It'll cancel out.
All right.
It's okay.
Two, four.
It's just five guys.
Five dudes are at the hospital right now.
We have no health care, but that's okay.
They'll be fine.
Okay.
Grab more DPS.
Nani Rams.
We can do AoE, so it should be okay.
We are...
I'm 68 now.
Oh my god.
Our...
Why is nothing dying?
Oh my god.
I wish things die a little faster.
Not gonna lie.
What if more paladins though?
Don't worry.
We're so kidding against crabs now.
Oh, one ninja dude's down.
Don't worry except for that one guy.
Guys, see I told you we're late game.
We're late game guys.
We're late game.
Turbo team.
You're my dude gains.
Oh, all dudes gain block.
Okay, guys, we can only pick one.
Block or turbo team.
You can always have more pal- Exactly, exactly.
More paladins.
We're late game.
This is late game.
Block.
Okay.
Jesus Christ, that's a lot of dust.
Believe in the late game build.
Oh, shit.
Quick chance.
Two burn for Williams.
We're going to do get thrown.
I feel like...
Battle standard, right?
All right.
Okay, nice.
Another meteor.
Yeah, we stopped getting ghosts.
Wait.
You might have noticed that we stopped recruiting ghosts in
our team.
We sort of gave up on them It's okay, we have the cleric for
that
I don't know Do we want another ghost on a team?
You can sort of tell I gave up on them He can tell I cut
their funding
Unless we go with ninja More DPS More DPS?
Yeah, alright I knew it.
Alright, let's see.
There's attack power, max HP, hot pot, curry, or...
Oh, wait, cleave.
Should we get cleave?
And then give it to...
What do we give it to the paladins or ninjas or Vikings?
We get nan to the Vikings, maybe?
Nan to the Vikings, damn.
What do we give it to?
Nan to the Vikings?
Alright.
Jesus Christ I just hear dying ducks everywhere
Oh we bring it I didn't even realize when you told me to
bring it down I think it's because like there's just so much
screaming in my dying screaming in my ear
There's so many There's so much screaming And yelling
all right nice
all right paladins oh shit my ninja dudes and paladins came
back one polar bear let's go fight that polar bear showed
him what it's like to be extinct that's right everybody dang
about him kill him oh shit wait not me wait a minute i was
to kill him i didn't mean kill my guys Ew.
Oh, shit.
More dude juice.
That's what we need.
Um.
I'm going to get the living will at this point.
And then a.
I got dude juice.
I should have enough.
I'll do restock first.
And then.
I'll grab bean burrito and also a dude juice.
I think that's good.
And we'll fight 58 geese.
That is a lot of geese.
That might be a lot of geese there.
Okay, more Vikings.
When do I get them back?
Two rounds.
One, two.
Another investment.
I might need it.
2% 20% chance.
I'll take this.
I'll take that chance.
That's right.
I knew it was a good idea to take that chance.
Oh, I lost this one ghost, dude, but that's okay.
Oh my god, the horse is scared.
The unicorns are scared.
Yeah, I was going to say, I'm just like, do I want to fight
the geese?
And I was like, ooh, I don't do really well with the geese,
to be fair.
It's okay, the late game.
The late game, guys.
We're late game filled.
We're almost there.
We've almost reached our full potential of late game.
Wait, we're almost there.
The potential.
The late game potential, guys.
Trust the process.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
One ninja down.
I repeat.
One ninja is down.
Heal per attack.
Yeah, I just need... I hope it comes up, though.
We only have two dudes right now.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
We're so used to fighting Ram.
It's okay.
We fought, like, 8 million Rams.
What's another Ram?
How's another Ram gonna do?
Alright, yeah.
Alright, now they're gonna go...
Now they're gonna die fast.
He just tanked up a lot of damage.
Might want to get more clerics?
Say less.
I got you.
Oh, I wish I got this.
Why did I invest?
Oh, man.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
We can just buy more do juice.
It's fine.
Okay, just in case.
I'm going to send a meteor in.
Just in case.
Something bad's happening.
going to happen to me.
We're just going to set a mean here out there.
Just in case.
Guys, we're late game.
Oh, we are so late game.
We are just really, really late game, guys.
We're just really, really late game, everybody.
That's just how it is.
We are so late game, everyone.
We're just so late game.
We are so late game.
See, I told you.
I told you.
We're late game.
We're just...
Okay.
Cleric or Viking?
We...
Yeah.
Cleric or Viking, guys?
Cleric?
Okay.
Found a relic stash.
The cleric gains 10% toughness and now applies temporary
health of his DPS up to cleric dude gains and his divine
healings increases by I feel like Incense Holder, right?
Or Golden Shield.
Incense Holder or Golden Shield?
Okay.
shield or protective cloak all right shield okay
all right which one Riz ADHD or laser pointer
Riz on ghost we have six ghosts I've given up on the ghost
I've given up on them they're Their funding's been cut.
So, y'all tell me which character is getting this.
This is a dragon build, by the way.
I've cut their funding.
They're on their own.
Good luck.
Reroll?
I don't have one reroll left.
I don't know if I want you wasted on this one.
Alright, fine.
I'll waste it.
This track.
Okay.
I know...
Okay, which one?
This track on...
Berserker?
Tattoo on the Vikings?
Okay.
Alright, this track on Vikings.
Alright, last two.
Do not worry.
4, 5, 6.
I'll use it.
I'll get 75 of them back up.
This should be enough.
Guys, I don't know if that was enough.
I don't know any.
I don't know That's enough.
Okay, that was enough.
That was a little scary, but that was enough.
That was a little scary.
Okay, that was enough though, at least.
Shield belt, nanomachines.
I don't know.
That was a little close.
Is it worth it?
Do you think it's worth it, guys?
Do you think it's worth it?
Because I don't know.
I don't know if it's worth it.
I was only slightly terrified.
I know the button would be good.
Okay, I'll give the deal.
I was just a little worried there.
Just a little bit worried.
But I know my dude's got it.
I know they got it.
I got it.
Okay, nice.
You want palinins or cleric?
Palinins or cleric, dragon wounds?
This is your build.
This is your time to shine.
It's your build.
Pals?
More heals?
All right.
I saw more people say more heals.
Dog size rats.
I'm not taking any chances right now.
I don't think I'm that desperate for the money at the
moment.
I just want my pal dudes to survive like my dudes just need
to live that's all I care as long as they're alive their
whole soul mission is to survive all
right nice I don't even know how many dudes I have not gonna
lie.
I've lost count
Oh everything is so expensive now.
I'm so poor
Oh, I'm so poor.
I'll just buy some more dude juice.
I'm so poor Oh,
I'm not any poor okay
Okay.
Here we go.
Dude, you got some nice relics there.
I know where to find more, but it's more date.
Okay, let's see.
Ritual sword for the mixtape.
Loki's arm.
Or... I don't think it's worth it.
Nah.
Unless, maybe the ritual dagger for mixtape?
I don't know.
so.
I think I get dismissed this.
These items are not worth it for me.
I already lost the hope.
Mixed tape is worth it?
You think so?
Maybe for the...
I'll do the mixed tape.
Alright, we'll do mixed tape then.
Only because, like, at least, like, I'm still... I still
feel hope for my ninjas, you know?
Like, my ninjas, they're still...
I still believe in them.
Not you.
I don't...
Yeah, long-term investment.
We lost it, Cleric.
Jesus Christ.
Alright, nice.
Kabakarilla.
Okay, okay.
What's the...
we're getting mixed table.
We'll get the ninja, dude.
432.
Yep, let's go.
Yeah, we're ghosting the ghost dudes.
Jesus Christ.
The sounds of rats dying in my ears.
Give me so much joy.
Uh...
Here you go.
What the fuck?
you whoa oh this is not good how are you guys dying so oh my
god they're dropping like flies oh my god it's okay i
believe my paladins are there slow and steady
okay vikings when a dude robsies healing gains oh okay all
right we can only afford one do we get the bloody talisman
or holder they're both good
incense or tap lovely talisman i see more bloody talisman
than incense yield potency potential incense sounds better
they're both good so i don't know incense is really good all
right we'll grab incense then and then we'll grab more juju
have smuggler dudes gonna return and then we'll get an
investment i have regular i i don't think any regular dudes
join they they're too scared guys they're too scared to join
not because of like anything else it's just you're scared of
the you're just scared to join our team because we're just
so good so they're intimidated by the way not because you're
scared of dying you're just intimidated by us
That's it.
You're just intimidating how cool we are.
Alright, loyalty card.
When a dude gets knocked out, all dudes gain one speed.
When any dude gets knocked out, all dudes.
Okay, do we get Cage Tiger or Dog Tag?
Yeah, by the aura.
Guys, I don't think we get...
Loyalty card is not going to help us.
We're always just poor.
Guys, If every dude chips in $10, maybe we won't be poor,
dude.
All right, cage tiger.
Dude, we just need every bro to chip in.
Okay, two rounds.
Am I going to survive?
Yeah, I'm going to survive two rounds.
Actually.
Okay.
Now that I see how many goats are there,
I didn't think I sort of didn't really think this through
because I didn't realize exactly how many goats I sort of I
might have stopped reading
all right dang button Medical nanites, nanomachines, sun, or
warp deck.
Three?
Button?
What nanomachines, though?
All right, button.
I don't know if it's worth...
Okay, they're gonna revive now.
Okay, I'm gonna risk it.
I think we're gonna...
be five
yeah we're five we're so five see risking it is always okay
all right uh dps or cleric guys dps support
bump bump bump bump bump bump bump dps all right cha-ching
nice and one round 86 okay I don't need to rise anything
then.
Alright, we'll grab here.
Oh my god.
I am a little worried.
This grass does not look so good.
Oh,
it's fine.
We recovered.
Oh my god.
Wow.
Got a little...
You know what?
You can have a friend.
You don't fucking have a friend.
I feel nice today.
You can bring your friend along this time.
I felt good today.
And they made it in.
I'll let one ghost into the team.
I'll treat I'll treat myself all right universal health care
dog tag it are any of these I guess universal health care
would be good to get then I'll
restock um I don't know I should get dog tag because like
what if the restock is good you know both are good you think
it's worth it because like I can what if I do a re-roll and
it's better I'm gonna re-roll I'm gonna are you serious I
shouldn't have re-rolled I mean I could restock again can I
restock again yeah these are both bad oh wait okay I'm gonna
try to put give this to I could put the cleric at the top
The hat Don't buy Blue Juice What do I put at the top then?
Cleric?
Or the Vikings?
Viking or Ninja?
I feel like Viking Could be better Just because I don't know
Viking or Ninja and just Viking?
Alright.
Hold on.
Okay, I grabbed my dude.
Oh my god, that's a big knife.
That's a
that's a big of a knife.
Not gonna lie.
Alright, it's okay.
They're all on the tiger now.
Oh shit, that poor cleric.
I'll show you a knife.
I'll grab Viking just because he has the big ass bug.
too.
And around, we'll get three more.
We'll get the scavenger dudes gonna return, and we'll get a
boss fight later.
That's nice.
I'll show you a knife.
Holy shit.
My ninja dudes.
Oh my god!
It's okay.
The Vikings are still going strong, though.
The Vikings are still going berserk mode.
That's enough.
Grab more Viking dudes.
Alright, now we have mixtape as well so my ninja dudes are a
little bit more buffed up okay 443 seagulls let's go whoa
heal him heal the viking keep healing
okay more vikings uh round two we'll get more we're at the
boss fight almost This is gonna get a little bit crazy soon
Okay, everyone on the tiger quick Okay, DPS or support DPS
or support guys quick Okay, I do need paladins now.
Alright, we'll grab paladins later Whenever we see one DPS
or support DPS?
Okay.
Eh.
Alright, we'll have a lot.
Wait, who's coming back?
Okay, the ninjas.
The ninjas are coming back here.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, it's time.
More than ninjas.
We'll come back.
We'll trade in.
Oh, whoa.
Whoa.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay, it's like a little trade from one ninja to the next
ninja.
Okay, Ron and all dude- Wait, this is good.
Ron's sake?
We should take it, right?
The attack speed?
And the same amount just died.
Rest in peace to the ninjas.
Yeah, tagging and tagging.
Yeah, they tagged in.
Okay, we'll grab.
We'll grab another do-juice.
I'm just gonna rest them all just because like we need as
many dudes as possible And then I'm gonna send a meteor to
the gorillas and hope for the best
All right, we're gonna send it Here and hope for the best
now and then we're gonna give everyone temporary HP and and
then maybe res a couple more and then I'll send meteorite
one more time here and hope for the best and then put more
temporary HP bring five more people in and then it should be
five we're good dude just really taxi can I get it well
thank you in the super chat thank you thank you okay all
right um whoo
that dude that was close.
That was a little close, dude.
Alright.
I didn't hear no belt.
Alright, guys.
Two.
The Palladrons.
Alright.
Okay, now this one goes on the ghost.
So, like, to be fair, it really doesn't matter.
Um.
Like, this is just for the ghost.
So, like, this is sort of a throwaway trinket at that point.
Riz for the poor ghost?
We might as well.
Give that ghost some Riz.
Alright, someone said I should put the clerics at the top.
Should I do that?
Someone said I should put the clerics at the top.
Should that be what I should do?
We'll heal everybody up just in case.
for boss but this is all boss fights
yeah all right here we go i don't i don't know how this is
gonna go but here we go oh my god oh
i hope they're all oh i oh my
I'm trying not to waste too many heals right now.
No, this might be dangerous.
I'm scared.
I'm a little scared, guys.
okay we're we're late game it's okay everyone we are late
game oh we are so late game we are so very late game it's
okay this is a late game build oh oh It's just unicorns.
It's just unicorns left.
It's all gonna hit at the very, very late game.
Oh.
Okay.
I don't have a lot of dude juice left, guys.
Oh, dear.
Oh,
okay.
I'm going to send a meteorite in just in case.
Just a...
In case we need it type deal, which might be the case.
Okay.
Oh.
No more dude juice.
Maybe?
Oh, the clerics are falling a foal.
Oh, no.
Oh, whoa.
I missed my, I missed my, oh geez.
The massacre.
I just wanna beat this game.
We gotta keep going.
We gotta beat this game.
I'm sorry I'm sorry we got we got to beat it we got to beat
the goat we gotta believe all right dragons you told me this
was the best build dragons
I did your build.
I didn't hear no belt.
Someone said if he doesn't have one active for each of us,
the quantum dude heals the most.
Oh, wait, that's good.
I think we can do this.
Oh, my God.
Wait, we got it.
Wait, I think there are too many cooks in the kitchen.
All right.
Oh.
Wait.
Quantum Tunnel or Entanglement?
Oh, they're so good.
Oh, wait.
The Tunnel or Entanglement, too?
Tunnel, okay.
That's a lot.
Wait.
That's like four guys.
Oh, my God.
Ender Healing.
Wait a minute.
That sounds so OP.
Wait, this might be it.
This actually might be it.
Okay.
He taunts for...
Okay, wait, the taunt.
We need taunts, right?
Pirate, medic, or mutants?
Reroll?
Or medic, or pirates, or mutants?
It's a bad taunt.
Oh, medic is so OP.
Okay, I'll do medic.
Okay.
I think we can have...
Oh, nobody's gonna die here.
Okay, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, I think we're good.
I think we're good.
I think this is good.
I'll grab another Quasi-Dude.
That's like six dudes.
We'll buy the rubber gloves, and then we'll get a free dude
juice.
And then we'll restock and grab another dude juice.
Okay.
We're making so much money, too.
We have, like, six guys.
What's better than...
What, three guys?
Six guys.
We'll grab another.
Oh, my God.
You know what's better than six guys?
Oh my god!
You know what?
You know what's even better than six guys?
Oh, there's so many dudes now!
Exponential dudes.
Okay.
Reroll?
He's back.
Wait, the zombies were so clutched though with tanking,
right?
I don't remember.
They were, right?
Or the knight.
Wait, which is better?
Knight, they're both, they're both like taunters.
Do you want knight or...
Zombies.
Zombie, then all DPS, or knight, and then all DPS.
They're both tanks, right?
Zombie?
Okay.
Grab zombie then.
Oh my god, this is going crazy.
I'll grab another medic.
Just in case.
And then we'll grab another tank too.
And after that, we're all in on the quantum bros.
Our quantum bros DPS, I can't tell.
I was...
I said the tip...
There's just so many guys.
I can't tell if they're considered DPS or not.
I...
We couldn't get the...
Oh, hey.
Grand.
Oh, hybrid DPS.
Oh, they're everything.
Oh, they're DPS healers.
Okay, do we get black sheep or medical bag?
We can get black sheep and then put it on the quantum.
The bag?
Okay.
I can actually do, like, the big boss fights now.
agent dude when he oh is that oh a bard dude every 10 times
four times he deals there bard plays son inspires four
random news granting effects time except when he deals he
has a 50 chance of any duty dashes become insist means
temporary okay put the sheep on the okay wait we get bard or
agent bard get bard
We have technically three supports right now.
Should we get another support?
Reroll?
What if we get shittier?
Alright.
Oh shit, vampire?
Oh!
Wait!
Is this DPS?
I can't tell.
Should we get vampire?
Or psionic dude?
Are we going to get triple support?
Life still is great.
We have zombie for the time.
Okay.
Get this vampire.
I'll get this just in...
I don't know if I should re-roll.
They're all like knockout relics.
Okay.
And I feel like it's not worth it.
I'm going to restock.
I'll get the force field.
And then I'll get a force field.
Oh my god.
The vampires just beat up the one crow.
He's all by himself.
He's like, don't worry, guys.
I got him.
And don't worry.
I got this.
He's just like, he's like, he's taking care of it himself.
So.
Oh my god, here we go.
Can you claim reward?
Grab another medic, just in case.
3% attack power.
One minute dude that drops all minute dudes gain.
I feel like venomous lipstick.
God give that homie a kiss.
God give that homie a little kiss.
A little muah-wah.
You know?
Yeah, you can reduce enemy hit power.
So I'm grabbing their...
Oh, we're speedrunning this.
Where's my quantum dudes at?
Bro, where the fuck is my quantum?
Oh my god, that regular dude.
Don't worry, guys.
Don't come over.
I kissed the homies.
Good night.
Any roster dude takes to fill.
He has 50% chance to absorb.
An echo dude to fully heal himself.
This destroys the echo dude.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, that's a hand sanitizer.
Respect the one, bro, respect the 1v1, bro.
Are you guys showing me this box?
Alright, we'll get the box.
What's better than eight dudes?
Oh, oh, hey guys, it's better than eight dudes, guys.
Oh my god, what's better than 10 dudes?
Yeah, I feel like...
time sink we can only get one time sink or old jacket
the zombie dude gains 20 24 max hp or deflect or 3 attack
speed
jacket and i'll buy this find the new that all right time to
beat up the babies we got this we're so used to beating up
babies it's nothing
All right, here we go.
And more quantum dudes.
More!
I demand more.
Oh my God, these crabs are nothing.
More!
More quantum dudes!
More, I see!
Holy shit.
Oh, shit, I forgot I had one more guy.
Um.
Alright, hammer toss.
Viking or cowboys or construction or re-roll.
We could re-roll.
Vikings with life steel.
But he's the cowboys are so cool.
Guys, I need like...
Guys, we got... I want to beat the game.
guys.
I want to beat the game.
Reroll.
Alright.
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
Spartan!
Beams around him, dude, and leave above him.
I feel like Spartan, right?
I don't know if he's a tank.
He seems like a tank.
I don't know if he's DPS or not.
Or Alien.
Alien?
What would be better?
Alien or Spartan.
I feel like Explorer is just a support.
I think we have enough skills.
We might need DPS.
I don't know.
Half tank, half DPS.
Spartan?
More support for the quantum?
If he was a random dude of the dude type, immediately above
him on the wrong Uh...
Does he like...
Wait, does he make more men?
Oh!
He doesn't, okay.
Oh, he's like Samurai by extra steps.
Okay, which one should we get then?
I don't know.
Alright, aliens are Spartans, guys.
Okay, he makes them dash.
I see.
He's just dashing with extra steps.
okay alien spartan guys alien here i see more okay spartan i
see more spartans okay i'm grabbing spartans another regular
dude i'll grab another spartan then if ever i see quantum
dudes i just automatically get quantum dudes though Each of
us are that con grants equal to Wait, when a buyer deals
direct damage, she marks the target soul for finitude damage
the deals for Oh, they're all so good Oh Dragon, this is
your chance to shine Two All right, the quantum nugget Oh my
god, I forgot what it was like to like Take the expensive
option I forgot what that was like.
To fight the expensive, the expensive monsters.
Oh, dang.
He has 3% chance to grant temporary health.
I'll grab the O'Ding button.
I like the O'Ding button a lot.
Yeah, we're just priority.
Oh no, the quantum dude!
Why did he, oh no!
Oh no!
He tried to solo the duck!
What are you doing, bro?
Bad, bad, bad.
You're not strong.
Oh, we need more DPS.
We, oh, we gotta.
We might need more DPS, guys.
Alright, hey.
We're quantum dudes, though.
Loyalty card.
One dude takes damage, drops his HP, gains.
100% cleave.
Okay, rage bait or loyalty?
I respect, bro.
You tried a solo.
The goose.
Loyalty card or a cage tiger?
We'll grab vampire next.
Reroll?
I only have one reroll left.
I don't know if I should waste it on early.
I don't know if I should waste it this early, though.
loyalty early okay we all their gains when you life still oh
wait we should give this to the quantum or like oh or
medical license on quant oh we could give all of these for
quantum they're all good they're all so good
oh i don't know
quantum All right, we'll give this on Okay, I'm quantum
We'll give him the medical license I was just thinking
they're all so good Okay This is okay We're doing a lot
better We are We're all healing
All right, more quantum dudes You know what?
I think we can beat up these goats we have so many men and
we sort of need the money right now wait we really need
don't worry this is the late this is early and late build I
think this is it I think the third one is it this early and
late build I think we got best of both worlds
oh wait oh my god which one they're all so good the belt the
belt that would go to our quantum dudes
all right okay 30 attack power oh my god oh my god look at
them go look at my quantum oh look at them go there's so
many of them goodbye that's just awkward okay do we get
spartan or medic i don't even know the medic you a heal
anymore like quantum or nothing like does it matter who i
pick here no
medic all right all right 283 bees i think i i ain't afraid
of all these bees now
oh it's like you thought you'd get away from us a quantum
oh my god you should pick the medic dude he has a cool hat
okay zombie or spartan i will just grab spartan fuck it
we'll just balance them out at this point
all right we can only buy one which one do you want mori
healing received or block chance i feel like healing
received right because It's just everybody can heal.
Yeah, they're all just healers at this point.
The thing is, I don't know who's better out of the zombie
and the Spartan.
Because, like, okay, vampire.
Just for the life steal.
You know what?
Dude gains.
Oh, yeah, let's go.
Is it worth it?
Should I give them the box?
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's go.
even need to think about it i'll give him the box i think
the exchange is good good enough
yeah i think it's good enough but we're all in on quantum
bros all right zombie or medic guys yeah get it back later
i was just like it i'm fine with that and we're just renting
it out zombie or medic zombie more ass Okay.
Where are my quantum bros at, though?
Where are my quantum bros at?
Oh, my God.
I'm with training.
I hope the dude whisper comes back, so I could make more
quantum bros.
All in on quantum bros.
Look at all these regular dudes.
Oh, my God.
There it is.
Where's the dude whisper?
He's coming in next round.
The dude whisper is coming in next round.
Yeah, don't worry.
Don't worry.
He's coming in hot.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Quantum, dude.
Yes!
Put them all in.
All in.
Oh, my God.
The sound of babies.
Oh, it's just the entire floor.
It's just red.
Oh, my God.
And there's more Quantum, dudes.
when taking that is to heal for 100% taken I'll get the
sewing kit right
okay we're gonna have that and then zombies are the vams
yeah but if I'm giving the option for pod names I'll always
pick it 100%
we're so healthy guys we're so healthy oh that horse is
running away oh he's so scared all right we'll grab grab
another tank and another regular dude sweet bat wings take
the life skills from until his hp and the teleports away oh
which one bat wings or we'll grab medic next time uh bat
wings are purple heart
i see more threes three okay oh shit burner phone Jesus I
have 30 extra guys just 30 extra guys I don't even know if I
have enough DPS to be fair I just have guys just beating
people up okay oh
medical or spartan because i don't know i like when i'm not
given the choice of quantum dude i don't know what to get
when i don't have the quantum because i'm always all in on
quantum and then like i'm like i have i'm like oh yeah i
have other dudes but like what what do i get okay 10
deflection
Quantum.
Oh, yummy.
Right?
Pop-pop for Quantum.
Yeah?
Alright, Quantum.
You're all in.
Now you're even stronger.
Oh, you're so strong.
My beefy little guys.
So beefy.
He will be my DPS.
Shh.
Don't worry.
Look at Doki's here for you.
Quantum is all we need.
Oh, Ramnir's Spartan.
Oh, 97 Quantum, dude.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, that one medic.
He's soloing him.
46 echoes.
You know what's better than that.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Every five seconds, the quantum grants 20 for nearby dudes
and teleport soon.
Oh, dudes, gain!
Wait.
Okay, we have to get that.
I don't care.
We have to get the cleave.
Oh, dudes, gain cleave?
Like, sayanara.
Oh, dudes, I have 46 echoes.
Quantum.
Oh.
my god i have not seen the hp go down i think i might go in
with like 40 health potions at this point oh shit hey oh
goodbye it's like it's like the nuclear launch code i'm like
oh shit go all in let's go give me all the money
I'm watching the nuclear launch code in action.
We'll get Spartan.
This is...
Oh my god, this is it.
We get it.
We're doing it.
I don't have to do the pussy shit.
The fighting, the weaker opponents.
My dudes got this.
This We have more echoes than I've always believed in my
bros
Oh my God These snakes are so tanky but it's okay I can play
the long I can wait I can wait Grab the zombie The third
dude Gains crit chance Oh, dude's getting...
Okay.
Do we re-roll or do we get one or two?
This is just the jumping team.
Re-roll or one or two?
Re-roll?
Alright.
Ooh, okay.
Oh.
Oh, we're running the ancient sword.
Alright.
And so when he invades, he has 20% chance every second.
Rhyme dude below him onto a random distinct dude or in
random three more dudes.
I know I'm thinking about more dudes right now.
In a fight.
Give me socialism on the zombie.
Who should we give socialism to?
Who do we give socialism to?
Which dude should learn about socialism?
All I can think about is quantum.
Alright, zombies.
You've learned socialism.
Congratulations.
These are ones that I wish I had times 8 speed.
It's like an auto battle.
I just want to just click it to the end.
We'll just balance it out here.
Is there any of these I want?
Dude takes failed damage.
We do lands after being thrown.
Every time the merchant dude fades, he gains all dudes.
Oh, I would like the...
Oh.
Okay.
I feel like it's worth it.
Only because...
I would like the evasion stuff.
Yeah, or the overhealing.
I'll do it.
I'll do it for the overhealing.
Yeah, the overhealing sounds really...
nice right about now okay i need i'll grab another medic so
if i get the over oh my god the skittles are here summon
more dudes more dudes okay grab a vampire wow there's so
many dudes But it has like 60% over heal on every dude, but
we could have more.
But guys, we can have so much more.
I'm going to restock here.
Oh my god.
There's like a lid on the quantum.
all right forest field 15 healing then fuck it just just
give me everything i don't i think my dudes will be all
right i think it'll be all right okay more quantum oh sweet
that is
oh roll out quantum dudes are coming oh yo is that more
quantum dudes let's go
all right this is it guys i can't believe it's only my first
run guys you don't need to think or worry oh shit what do i
do now all right we'll grab one zombie i don't know what to
do now i don't have no quantum dude as an option possible oh
shit it took out one of my quantitudes how is this possible
you have so much use it's alright I don't grab a zombie
because he knows socialism all right you have deflect I know
I I have like some deflect stuff so I'll buy that for now
and then we'll grab one of the juice we're just stocking
that up for a late game because I'm worried about late game
they can die I know right I mean too I was just like that's
possible an additional skeleton dude every 10 rounds oh my
god we gotta grab that that's more dudes just imagine that's
so many dudes
Unlimited dudes.
Alright, nice.
Look at what you need to do to mimic a fraction of their
power.
All dudes gain invasion.
Overhealing.
Oh my god, yes!
Give me the overheal!
Yes!
Okay, here we go.
Rise my army Rise
Okay, we get knockout items The skeletons will like go
really hard here Okay, that unicorn is so fucking tanky Not
gonna lie It'll all be over healing
Okay, claim Grab vampire so we can get more lifesteal and
then fight i didn't realize the skeleton um is considered a
knockup character which would be smart to do we have a
knockout item that would give us like plus dps or some shit
oh universal health care we get more hp oh grab universal
health care And then, I think 20 juice is okay.
Oh, we have so much regeneration now.
And then we'll grab another one.
And then, we'll restock again.
And then, ooh.
We get more healing or do we get loose tooth, guys?
More healing or tooth?
tooth all right it's good
oh my god you might be full items try to get a second unit
there's a second unit
what what's a second unit a second unit What?
What's that?
Nonsense.
I've never heard of that word before.
Like the echoes, right?
You're talking about the echoes, right?
That's what you mean.
Just quad.
Yeah, the echoes.
They just...
In all of it!
Look at all the staggers being thrown out.
Oh shit, what are these guys?
I'm just like, what are you, I've never seen these two
before.
What?
I've never seen these guys before.
Yeah, Spartan is such a weird way to spell quantum.
I didn't realize quantum started with a...
Oh, my quantum dudes!
I didn't realize Quantum started with an S.
That's new to me.
It's okay, it's okay.
My Quantum dudes, they're so healthy.
I believe in the power of Quantum!
Okay, we need zombies for sure.
I just haven't had any zombies spawn in yet.
oh my god we all dudes getting shit okay false fangs or
bonfire they're both good maybe bonfire i'm gonna grab a
bonfire i know i asked you guys but lans is he has
permission chance to taunt it's too late i already got the
bonfire you're like three and i was like whoops
every every second the wheeler gains and the last for the
second up to five um we have re-roll I'm gonna re-roll it
when when the wheeler deals he has chance to equal to oh you
should grab that when the wheeler deals attack damage he has
chance to Shift for who, though?
Vampire or Spartan?
Or Medic?
Or two?
ADHD?
Put the taunt on.
I don't think I have taunt here.
We get rid of the vampire.
Or Medic?
I'll do a vampire.
Oh, it's fine.
I don't think we need to heal.
I think we're strong enough that they'll all come back.
It was just because of the boss fight.
I think if it's just a boss fight fuck me up there nothing
nothing that quantum can solve though like now I think I can
beat up 800 geese I possible oh my god yeah I had a feeling
I had I had a feeling it as possible.
Okay.
Dude, Lifestyle Games 4% cleave for two seconds.
Oh, we should get a heating pad.
The heating pad is so good.
100%.
Yeah.
Yeah, that cleave is going to do wonders for us.
Nice.
That quad quantum dude?
No, that is a quantum dude, bro.
Is that my good old buddy quantum dude?
I like how they stop giving me other units.
I... I...
I don't think I've seen a single zombie.
I'm sorry.
I don't think zombies even exist anymore.
A
quantum of army.
I don't, I actually don't think I've seen a single zombie.
Oh, we could get this for the, I'm gonna grab this just for
the, uh, the skeletons, because they're always dying.
And grab, so, we'll grab that.
Just because the zombie itself would deal with a little
burrito
Oh, dad.
Oh, shit.
Zombie or quant?
Oh, guys.
But quantum, though.
But guys.
Okay, I'll grab a zombie.
Fine.
Maybe that.
I'll give you that.
Fine.
I guess I'll use it.
The quad is...
That's a trick question, Doki.
Always quad him.
All right, gorilla down.
Gorilla down.
Oh my god, regular guy down.
Regular guy down.
I don't know how he got into the squad, but he's also down.
Who invited that guy?
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, the skeleton's coming back.
five only bears can hurt the quantum only one thing oh what
do i i don't know i mean
where's where's quantum sure guys i i mean i don't know if
it's because i can't read but like i'm having a hard time
trying to figure out where your quantum is i i'll just
balance it um
I bet it for safety.
Yeah, but I was thinking I might need it for late game.
I balanced it out just in case.
Oh, Jesus.
It's just the screams of Quantum.
It's alright.
Just a couple of horses left.
Alright.
Zombies.
Boss Fangs.
Reroll.
And then grab that there's stockpiling in heels just in case
just in case in the final boss where everything could go
wrong I just gotta be prepared in case everything goes wrong
at the end um wait oh my god all heels I don't even have to
read I saw an item for the quad bro and now it's just like
that's enough for me imagine we get nuclear launch good i
don't even know what that item does i thought item for
quantum dude and i was like here you go my sweet summer
child here okay attack power 20 max hp 50 crit i don't even
know like you're none of these will go to my quantum anyway
so like what's the point max hp on the zombie all right
nice like i'm just like items for like not quantum pro we
might as well fucking die
all right you know what spartan oh cha-ching nice
all right i'm just equalizing the other story they're all
just here to have fun
all right all right oh shit nice forgot you guys were here i
i just really forgot you guys were around
all right now this is an idle bath now i'm I'm playing an
idle game.
And Doki has no favorites.
I don't know.
Okay, I guess.
I mean, less, I guess, you?
Alright, Perry.
Oh, dude's gain.
Okay, I'll get the block chance.
I'll restock.
And then...
yeah purple heart and then i don't know i'll restock this
too and then
oh my god he's always getting heals he's always getting
heals oh my god my god my medic wait How did two people die?
This is impossible.
Is this a boss fight?
Me thinking of a five gifted ships.
Thank you.
I was like, my team can bleed?
Pathetic.
Wait, that wasn't even a boss fight.
How is that possible?
That's just impossible.
My team, I can't bleed.
He has a pathetic excuse of a dude squad.
I did not train no fucking weakness.
Even a god can feel pain.
I didn't train no pathetic dudes.
Alright, it's okay.
It's alright.
We got more items.
We need to leave behind the weakness of the flesh.
Kick them out of the dude ranch.
The dude rash didn't train, no weak pussies.
Alright, best.
Healing is useless.
You get one shot.
Alright, it should be fine now.
Okay, we're zombies because of all the busts we have.
Alright, boss is next.
Okay, everybody's healthy again.
Alright, nice.
That cleave is actually doing so...
Oh my god, the army of...
Knives coming in.
Sami.
Gravestone.
Ooh, if only.
If only I get that, because then the skeleton will just
keep, it will be like the...
I'll grab...
I'll just grab a dude juice just in case.
Alright.
I'm looking at my HP.
And we seem to be okay.
What the fuck happened?
That one fight where five guys got knocked down.
This shit is...
Like, this is a boss button.
This shit is easy as hell.
Like, they're doing nothing to my guys.
I think we're...
I think...
Guys, I think I created the perfect group of dudes.
I think I actually...
I did it.
I created the perfect group of dudes.
Guys, I...
I think...
I think it's perfect!
Oh
Wait, that's so good
Yeah All right, what what do we want here the bog at this
point like it doesn't really matter as much What the other
guys get The ultimate life form
uh bongo's suit or folding chair folding chair it's just
sparring dudes i guess sparring uh i'll guess i'll wait what
else i'll give it to the suit on clerics i don't even have
clerics guys yes the clerics don't even exist in my army
Oh my god.
At this point, they shouldn't even fight me.
They should just kill themselves in this game.
They just see my army of dudes and just be like GG's.
5% invasion.
Fuck it.
Let's go.
They should just spawn, like, internally combust at that
point.
There's no point.
.
Uh, we'll grab live still.
I can't believe I got tunnel early game.
Like, I actually got, like, the best RNG possible.
Let's see.
Spartan, just because he got the steel chair.
I gave him the steel chair anyway.
No honor in that.
Is it really more audible than fighting non-equanim dudes?
Half naked men?
What's more audible?
Fighting 100 plus half naked men?
Or just taking it, taking yourself out?
Where are you, Stalk?
I don't like any of this.
I'll buy that then.
It's three regular dudes.
Three future quantum dudes, you mean?
Let's see.
Bring it.
Quantum dudes.
Medic dudes.
Sewing.
Okay, we're not making the zombie dudes explode.
The zombie dudes need to stay alive.
They should definitely not explode.
oh my god beat him up and we're zombies
wait what how did he die what happened what happened it's
the bears oh it's the also why is that guy so fucking big
did he eat the quantum dude did he just ate one of them why
is he so big what did he do
He's like, I think he ate my quads, dude.
They just, they just threw up.
Because the guy just, he ate the echoes.
He was, he was so hungry, dude.
He was so hungry.
Oh my god, it's always the bears.
Oh my god, they keep.
getting bigger.
There's a lot more bees than I expected.
Life's here.
I don't like any of these.
Ah!
Come on!
Alright, give me one more.
Alright.
Fuck yeah.
I'll grab that.
Just because I do have the skeletons and it gives everybody
attack speed as well.
So I'll take those.
I'll take the skeleton.
Oh, five frames.
Can we get possibly any lower?
Jesus Christ.
Oh, he's getting bigger.
Feed him.
Feed the Spartan.
He's so hungry.
Feed him.
Oh, oh, great.
Why is he so big?
This makes 500 dudes.
Oh, shit.
He's so fast.
Oh, my God.
He's so fast, dude.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
8% ease.
He can't kill any of my dudes.
He's a glowing boy.
Really is.
They're so fast.
Uh...
Oh, cha-ching!
Cha-ching, baby!
Like, I don't even have to do anything.
Oh, shit, but it's the bears.
weakness right now well sort of they were yeah but we've
evolved we've adapted okay quantum and more quantum so happy
birthday Merry Christmas and happy anniversary by bears you
mean you mean the Spartans right oh my god it's just all
red.
I can't see anything else on my screen.
It really taunts up to...
Okay, I can move the zombies at the bottom.
I'm gonna buy this and then put the zombie at the bottom.
Oh my god.
Give me that.
And give me this too.
Alright, and then we'll move the zombie.
Okay.
At the bottom.
And then we fight.
Jesus Christ.
That's alright.
I make so much money anyway.
Oh shit.
One guy died.
How did he die?
Weak.
I didn't raise no weak.
Pussies in my team.
Get out and never come back.
Oh shit, another guy can't die.
I don't even know if I should, I should, yeah, I think I
should put it on the zombies only because there's, I have
second most people on my team is the zombies.
What the fuck?
What were the medics doing?
All right.
I mean, they'll come back.
I mean, I have so much self-heal, it's fine.
It's actually fine.
I guess, yeah, I think a bear, like, literally fucked up my
medics.
They're literally the only regular...
They're technically the regular guys on my team.
Um...
Get the Spartan for the block.
Yeah, they're there.
Now that we don't have regular guys, they are societies...
next my team the dude ran to the next regular guys don't
worry we're so fast now though 37 i'm how i'm building so
many skeletons oh my guys are so fast
yay all right everybody should come back before the boss but
which is what i'm looking for for to do Yeah, they're the
lowest in the hierarchy.
Yep, another one down.
Right here.
I got the tiger.
Now we focus it all on the bears.
Oh, shit.
A vampire got down.
It's alright.
Quantum.
Nice.
Medic, dude's game.
Ooh, okay.
This might be good.
Ooh.
I mean, I can buy both.
So it doesn't really matter to me.
3% max HP.
Fuck it.
You know what?
And I'll buy a dude juice on the road.
Fuck it.
You know what?
I feel so good.
Go do some shrooms.
I'll give you guys a little treat.
on the house go wild oh shit wait it's fine it's fine just
focus it on those two gorillas oh yeah on the house I just
bought the MPG oh Mizuki thank you the super chat super chat
thank you thank you yeah I use the MSI MPG 271 QR QD OLX 50.
It's a really good monitor.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm glad you bought the monitor.
Um.
I don't have this one.
Alright, bag of nuts.
Inhaler.
Chance.
Also heal our most injured roster.
Like, who is missing?
Okay.
Alright, we should put that on the medic, dude.
Just because it's the last.
one anyway all right uh you know what i have so many heals
just go in have fun let's pull heal out everybody go wild
just go wild enjoy your time
shit i think they're going wild guys.
I'm trying.
I think they are going a little.
They're going really wild.
Just a stroll.
Just a stroll in the park.
More quantum dudes.
Horses.
I'm a little frail of horses.
Actually, never mind.
Ducks gone wild.
We got this.
We got this in the bag.
Don't worry.
I have six meteorites, 27 G juice, and two lightning books.
For the goat.
I'm ready for the goat.
Hey, claim reward.
More Quasin dudes.
Oh shit, we are so spread out.
I ain't too worried now.
I saved all of them.
this for the goat.
Every single one of them.
99.
Look at that overheel goat.
I like how they just keep giving me a... They keep giving me
quantum dudes as well.
There's like no other choice here.
I don't see no other choice in this game.
Just more quantum dudes.
Oh, shit.
A second choice?
I don't think I've seen that before.
For each zombie dude on my team.
Give me, give me.
She siphons, dick salmon, she siphons, 20% from a random.
Healthier, rostogen, blood flies, bloodsucker, aura.
What's bloodsucker, aura?
Should we give blood, siphon?
Or no.
Is it worth it?
By the innards.
I am a coward.
Yes, I am.
I need to kill the goat.
This is it.
Get another in.
Just in case.
in case oh
my god i'm just gonna put a meteor right here just in case
just in case oh my god don't worry oh they're so fast oh my
god they're so fast
oh he did it holy shit it only took four Four hours!
It will.
Oh, we fucking did it.
That was some serious dude wrenching.
With enough practice, your dudes might even thirst more!
You want to continue this run?
Doesn't grant credit?
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
There is support.
Guys, I know we have a member stream next, but I want to
know how far this would take me.
Wait, wait.
Guys.
Wait, these guys are so strong.
What the fuck?
Unlimited.
Dude.
Okay, but what if... Okay, fuck.
Okay, we actually do have new members.
Okay.
Can I?
Oh, wait.
Oh.
You want to sign?
Nah.
Oh, I can continue my run, right?
Oh, I can.
Okay.
But we did it.
Great.
Thank you.
Welcome to the video.
Fine.
Welcome.
Oh, my God.
We did it.
I have to do the member stream, guys.
I'm not.
Dude, this is, like, so epic, bro.
Well done, bro.
Oh, I mean, solid thing.
It was super chat.
Thank you.
did it shout out to my quantum bros this is that was
addicting this is an addicting game i had a lot of fun i
might play i might play this off stream but um oh my god the
roguelix i knew like i had to put on 9 p.m i was like is 9 p
.m enough time i like told him i asked myself i was like huh
i hope 9 p.m is not too late i might be able to have like an
hour break in between stream and then oh my god wait it's
always roguelike it's always roguelikes they have a hole in
on me
they have a hole in me they have like fucking oh I don't
know and then it's like it's like you know just bros being
bros you know but they got me sucked me in so thank you
welcome to me oh bad sorry my brain's so fried with all
these dudes uh thank you for the five gift of ships thank
you thank you I'm gonna push the member stream 31 minutes so
I can have like a 30 minute buffer in between but thank you
all for watching I had a fun time playing how many dudes it
was a very addicting game um and as always everybody stay
hydrated posh check get up and around to get that blood
flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed because you
deserve it I'm gonna go take my 30 minute break to the
before the member stream I'll see you guys there bye guys
bye